Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Oh, Moin Leute!
Was war denn für Musik?
Schaut mal her!
Du willst wieder nicht, ja?
Das ist zu chill.
Mal wieder meine Lieblingsplaylist an.
Vielleicht geht das hier.
Geht auch.
So.
Mal hier.
so also muss gerade noch mal kurz mein brötchen fertig fordern mit erst vor einer halbstund wach
ich habe gestern ziel plus plus broker stellt gemacht auf stream war wieder grausam leute
ja ohne euch
bin an dem esp32 mit display rum gebastelt
Ich hab doch so... warte mal.
So.
Hätte ich gefordert, muss ich das Tablett hinstellen.
Ich hab doch hier so ein Teil von seit Monaten rumliegen.
dem ich immer ein bisschen rumbasteln einfach just for fun ich weil ich will dass wirklich
etwas großartig rauskommt aber das ding ist halt richtig nice hast alles mögliche integriert hast
esp 32 s3 hast einen fast zwei zoll lcd display hast buttons batterieanschluss das ist wirklich
so eigentlich der einst der besten boards was da brauchst du sonst nix hast alles dabei und
halt auch ein display genau hast zwei buttons das ist es drei ist nicht der der c6 ist glaube
ich der mit zigbee der hier ist mit wifi der mit zigbee ist glaube ich der esp32 c6
ich glaube so hieß das ding genau
das dick wie ding was man immer programmiert haben hängt man mir immer noch im stall und
das funktioniert so problemlos dass ich jetzt aus dem kopf gar nicht mal weiß was
eigentlich macht wofür es eigentlich da war
es ist im stall hin ich weiß es ich habe das immer in so eine wasserdichte box
rein gehauen ich war was macht das denn da hinten ich bin grad voll steht hat
voll auf dem schlauch temperatur vom teich gehen alter chat
chat warum wisst ihr das besser warum in meinem stall in sikbi gerät steht als
ich selbst temperatur vom teich ja genau kreuz wollen temperatur vom teich macht das richtig
mit so einem ds 18 20 temperatur sensor der fünf meter lang ist aber das ding genau heißt
das geil dass ihr das besser ist wie kommt es dass du wieder mir geht es besser dann einfach
So, machen wir mal Package Updates.
Zack.
While pleading edge, arch by the way.
Chat, jetzt wenn ihr gerade alle am Start seid.
Ah, mir läuft die Nase. Wartet mal kurz.
Wollen wir kurz muten.
So, ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ah ja, Chat, jetzt wo ihr alle da seid, ich habe mal eine Frage.
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was man Linux-technisch mit zwei 14-jährigen Schülerpraktikanten machen kann?
die haben höchst wahrscheinlich höchstwahrscheinlich keinerlei vorkenntnisse moin johnny
keinerlei vorkenntnisse vermute ich zumindest keinerlei vorkenntnisse was linux angeht
vibecoding ne ne ne ne vibegecoded wird dann nix
linux desktop in zählen damit erstmal rumspielen das problem ist die haben kein eigenes laptop
geschweige denn Laptop, auf dem sie irgendwas machen können.
Man muss denen irgendwas an Linux-Servern zeigen.
Ich weiß nicht, also ich habe gedacht, wir können ein bisschen Server in unserer Testumgebung in Anführungszeichen fixen.
Testumgebung, da guckt keiner so richtig drauf.
Da haben wir gefühlt 300.000 Monitoring-Fehlermeldungen.
Und da könnte man ein paar wieder ganz machen.
bunto web server installieren mit docker umspielen das blöde ist die können halt
nicht selbst machen weil ich halt kein eigener laptop haben also die müssen dann
an meinen laptop und die dürfen auch was machen ja also irgendwie mal ein paar
dateien löschen oder so setzte aber ist jemand der gar keine linux kenntnisse hat bin ich mir
unschlüssig ob man die also wenn die ein bisschen linux basic kenntnisse haben ja dann können die
die können die 23 easy aufgaben machen aber ich glaube kannst du den kein laptop stellen
gibt die dürfen keinen haben fragt mich nicht warum weil super krasse kür alles bei uns
ja kannst nicht mal ich verstehe den sinn ehrlich gesagt davon auch nicht zum
glück haben alle azubis eigene laptops ja so genau verstehe verstehe ich den
sinn auch nicht was was wie das warum und weshalb und nach keiner ahnung
bei uns ist das teilweise so secure dass du nichts machen kannst also du musst
teilweise echt sachen doppeln und dreifach aufwendig machen weil so secure
ist ja das sicher ein guter vorwand mit denen in euer erzeit zu gehen ja aber da
ist unsere gruppe nicht für zuständig
berechenzentrum manchmal manchmal frage ich mich so warum kann es nicht mehr so
so unkompliziert sein wie damals wo einfach jeder überall hin durfte
Also ich konnte in Frankfurt, also gerade noch zur Azubi-Zeit beim Provider, konnte ich in jedes Rechenzentrum rein, was die betrieben haben.
Egal, ob ich mit den Sachen, die da drinnen lief, irgendwas zu tun hatte oder nicht.
Du bist einfach hingegangen und konntest rein.
Vielleicht Datenbank-Einträge auslesen.
Ah, das ist so abstrakt irgendwie.
Also ich habe mir gedacht, wir räumen ein bisschen Testserver auf.
Ja, da haben wir, in Tests haben wir garantiert Server, wo Zertifikate abgelaufen sind, wo Festplatte fast voll ist, wo irgendwelche Dinger sind, irgendwelche Sachen gecrashed sind oder so, ja.
Da können wir uns ein bisschen durchkämpfen.
Mal so 1-2 Stunden.
Und ganz ehrlich, 1-2 Stunden reicht auch, wenn du noch nie was mit Linux gemacht hast.
dann raucht ihr der kopf danach wie lange sind die da ein tag am dienstag
also ich habe mir gedacht vielleicht habt ihr irgendwelche chlorreiche
high iq ideen weil ihr wisst ja chat 80 plus iq only
Ich würde die das machen lassen.
Da müssen sie sich ein bisschen konzentrieren.
Ich zeige denen, wie man Dateien löscht, wie man rauskriegt, wo am besten, also wo Speicherplatz voll ist.
Chat, jetzt könnt ihr mir mal eure krassen Linux-Skills zeigen.
Wie würdet ihr rauskriegen?
Also, passt mal auf.
Ich zeige euch dann auch mein Lieblingstool dafür, was in allen Package-Managern verfügbar ist.
guck mal so hier ich habe 77 prozent einer platte ist voll also sind noch 56 gigabyte frei wenn ich
jetzt mal gucken will was ich in meinem haupt in meinem hauptverzeichnis aufräumen kann wie
würdet ihr das machen jetzt gucken wo da besonders viel drin liegt was ich löschen kann wir können
nichts von github runterladen die udu ist schon mal nicht verkehrt wir können uns
wir können uns nichts von github runterladen oder sonst irgendwas ja das
schon mal gut also können so was hier machen ja das
funst noch besser noch besser wir können ich glaube sort minus n ist es
bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ja.
Sort minus N.
Ne. Warte mal. Wie war das?
Sort du output.
Sort minus H.
Sort minus H ist es.
Okay.
das ist das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt ja das schon mal nicht verkehrt da sieht man zumindest
so grob wo man hingeht da kann man nach tmp und sowas wie aber wisst ihr was mein lieblings tool
dafür ist nc du das ist jetzt was man nach installieren muss aber sie in jedem package
manager drin das kennt jetzt das heimatverzeichnis und dann kriegst du ein bisschen wie diese windows
tools kriegst du übersicht angezeigt wenn sie dann mal irgendwann fertig ist kriegst ein bisschen
übersicht angezeigt wo hier was wie belegt ist dann kannst du sagen aha guck mal hier cash in
cash kannst du rein wechseln a jet brains toolbox also so und wieder zurück seit tmp sind zwölf
sind 12 gesagt sie sp 32 rast zum beispiel ziemlich groß das könnte man löschen du kannst auch direkt
drin löschen mit D, aber das finde ich eigentlich ganz praktisch, weil er ersparest du dir 500
mal die U auszuführen.
Ne, nachinstallieren sehe ich nie als Problem, solange das aus dem Standard Package Repo kommt.
Also das ist mein Lieblingstool dafür, weil es überall dabei ist.
Da muss man sich nicht mit die U durch mehrere Verzeichnisse kämpfen oder sich irgendwelche
anderen Sachen ausdenken.
das ist nicht per default installiert aber das ist sogar bei red hat in den
repos mit drin also überall mit dabei den befehl einfach nc du und dann sagst
du punkt für das aktuelle verzeichnis in dem du drin bist
40 Gig in Local, ah ja, warum nicht?
Guck hier, da, bam.
Share.
Jetplanes.
Apps.
Da sind die ganzen IDEs drinne.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, das ist im Basic.
also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das in den Basic Red Hat Repos drin ist, nicht EPL.
Also ich habe das auf allen Servern, wo ich mich einlogge,
ist das das erste, was ich nachinstalliert habe am Anfang, als ich neu da war.
Wenn ich das immer sehe, wie du durchgehst.
Was meinst du?
Du meinst so, was man so
im Terminal tippt oder was meinst du?
Das ist einfach Übungssache.
Musst dir keine Gedanken machen.
Es gibt genug Sachen, wo ich auch absolut keinen Plan habe.
In der Regel würde ich sogar sagen,
ich habe von deutlich mehr Sachen keinen Plan.
Wie von Sachen, wo ich
keinen Plan habe.
Also jetzt mal nur auf Linux bezogen.
Also, das ist tatsächlich so ein Ding, was viele Leute haben, die von Windows kommen.
Weil bei Windows kennen die Leute nur dieses Oldschool-Terminal mit Batch.
Und das ist der größte Scheiß, den es gibt.
Und das ist das, was viele Leute kennengelernt haben als Terminal und Shell.
Und die denken, das ist alles, was so aussieht, ist so.
Das Ding ist halt, dass das unter Linux einfach viel viel besser ist
Sowohl die Terminal Software als auch die Shells sind einfach doppelt und dreifach besser
Oder zehnfach, hundertfach besser als das alte CMD Fenster und Batch
Da muss man sich überhaupt keine Gedanken machen unter Linux
Unter Linux ist es sogar so, dass man mit der Zeit, wenn man eine Weile das Ganze benutzt und sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt hat
viele sachen lieber im terminal macht weil das einfach immer in irgendeiner art und weise
reproduzierbar gleich funktioniert und man sich nicht merken muss wie man wie bei welcher
distribution wie wo klicken muss und viele sachen gehen halt auch einfach schneller im terminal und
spätestens wenn du halt sachen machen muss die sich wiederholen oder die du öfters machst das
terminal einfach beste gibt natürlich immer noch sachen da kommst jetzt nicht drum herum
um eine UI-Anwendung zu verwenden.
Das beste Beispiel ist Webbrowser.
Macht keinen Sinn, dass irgendwie im Terminal,
ich weiß, es gibt so ein paar Spielereien für Leute,
da gibt es beispielsweise, habe ich letztens wieder gesehen,
gab es ein Projekt, das hat im Hintergrund in Chrome gestartet
und dann irgendwie als Images ins Terminal gerendert.
Das ist reine Spielerei, das ist Schwachsinn, das braucht man nicht.
Da kommst du im UI-Anwendung nicht drum herum.
Aber für so Daily-Sachen hier ist Terminal das Beste.
Ja.
Also finde ich.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund,
warum ich kein Fan bin von
Vim-Motions überall.
Also Vim-Motions ist ja
HJKL
zum Navigieren.
Also in Vim
hast du hier
drückst du H
und L für links und rechts
und JK für hoch und runter.
So, und da gibt es Leute, die sagen,
da gibt es Leute, die sagen,
wenn du deine Hände,
du hast die rechte Hand,
hast du hier drauf,
Wenn du deine Hände immer auf der Home-Row hast, wie das die Wim-Hackermans nennen, dann bist du überall viel schneller und es ist viel effektiver und viel besser.
Ich finde das stimmt nicht, weil du switchst ja im Alltag zwischen Terminal, Wim und Browser total oft.
und was willst du
einen Browser bedienen
wenn deine rechte Hand
da irgendwie auf HJKL ist
du musst eh zur Maus greifen
und da bist du permanent
damit beschäftigt
da irgendwie permanent
deine Hand zu positionieren
zwischen dem wenn du ins Terminal gehst
und dann musst du wieder rechts rüber greifen zur Maus
ich weiß nicht
also
ich bin da nicht so überzeugt von
um dem entgegenzuwirken
probieren manche Leute ja ihren Browser
mehr WIM mäßig zu machen
so mit WIM Shortcuts und sowas
aber ich hab das schon ausprobiert
da gibt es
ganz gute Extensions
aber da muss ich sagen, ein Browser bedient sich
trotzdem immer noch mit Maus am besten
ja ich weiß
es gibt es, aber trotzdem
es bedient sich mit der Maus einfach am besten
spätestens so Sachen, wenn du sagen wir mal hier hin musst und was markieren
mach das mal mit diesen WIM Extensions
das ist super hakelig
also deswegen
finde ich wird das von manchen
WIM Enthusiasten zu religiös da gepredigt
mit HJKL Movement überall
und Hände ständig auf der Home Row und sowas
welchen browser das firefox ich habe aber alternativ auch noch chromium und chrome und
noch mal firefox und die frage warum ich hast du schon sie ja habe ich probiert in der vm hat
funktioniert profi daheim auf dem rechner noch nicht dabei ist das eine sache ich muss einfach
im bios secure boot einschalten gucken ob es geht wenn das team die hat nicht mal auto completion
mittlerweile glaube ich schon mit also mittlerweile haben wir auch ein
gescheites neues terminal was gar nicht mehr so schlecht ist und hier ich glaube
an den wald des powerpoint also mittlerweile hat man hier guck hat man
auto komplett so halbwegs auto komplett die frage irgendwo gab es die frage
warum ich überhaupt noch windows benutze ich finde es jetzt gar nicht wo ist das
denn hier windows
jetzt blöd wo war dann die frage ja warum benutzt du eigentlich noch windows
Das ist ganz kurz und knackig beantwortet, warum ich noch Windows nutze.
Wegen Spielen.
Und wegen Streaming und Video-Editieren.
Wobei ich das theoretisch auch unter Linux machen könnte.
Vielleicht mit ein paar Einschränkungen, aber würde funktionieren ohne Probleme, denke ich.
Das, was ich da mache.
Aber zu 90% sind es Spiele.
Ich will dann einfach sicher sein, dass wenn ich ein Spiel installiere, dass das funktioniert.
Und halt auch was mit Anti-Cheat im Zweifelsfall.
Das neue Battlefield bin ich mal gespannt, ob das unter Linux laufen würde.
würde
schreibst du bestript johann paar wieso also machst du das öffnen hast du tipps
bin auch die luxe also als linux nut ist vielleicht jetzt mit best scripting
direkt starten nicht so sehr the way weil ich mein best scripts sind ja im endeffekt nur eine
große ansammlung von kommandos von shell commands mit ein paar keywords und kontrollstrukturen
drumherum aber selbst sind es selbst sind in bash kannst du ja mit also wenn es in best machen
willst kannst du auch so was hier sagen 111 ich weiß manche leute schwören er auf klammern und
also das heißt was einfachste und beste was du machen kannst ist es einfach benutzen also
täglich einfach dein linux benutzen am besten auch kommandozeile benutzen und keine angst vor
der Kommandozeile haben und wenn du da dich gut bewegen kannst, dann kannst du dir mal überlegen,
okay gibt es ein paar Sachen, die dich nerven oder du sagst, okay ich baue mir mal einen Alias
beispielsweise in der Shell für. Als Alias kannst du dir einen eigenen Befehl erstellen, der dann
drei, vier andere Befehle ausführt. Ich habe auch ein paar Aliasse, was habe ich denn für Aliasse?
image cat kubectl ist k zum beispiel ja und so auf startenden peisen http server und
so auf das aktuelle directory alias neo fast so ein paar dinge habe ich ja kannst du kannst
dann alias kannst alias erstellen und irgendwann hast du vielleicht auch mal
die visa wie sagen die bwl leute dazu denied irgendwann hast du vielleicht
auch mal bock zu sagen ich habe da was größeres was automatisiert werden soll
oder ich will irgendwas was ich immer wieder mache was ein bisschen komplexer
ist will ich einfach ausführen können dann kannst du bestes kopf erstellen
so
Und dann ist das beste einfach anzufangen und da kommst du auch dann ganz gut durch
Weil du kennst ja schon viele best kommandos und weiß wie das auf der shell machst
Also das beste ist immer wenn du weißt wie das auf der shell machen würdest um das dann in den
best script zu gießen im endeffekt
Aber das einfachste am anfang ist wirklich täglich täglich linux benutzen
Ganzes Skript in eine Zeile, ja das geht bei Bash auch gut.
Und fang am besten nicht an dein Bash Skript zu wipecoden.
Nicht weil es nicht funktioniert, ich würde sagen für viele Sachen wird es wahrscheinlich
ganz gut funktionieren, sondern weil du es erstmal verstehen musst, was da raus kommt.
Bringt ja nix.
Wenn du dir alles zusammen wipecodest und wenn dann mal was nicht geht, keine Ahnung
was los ist oder dass im zweifelsfall irgendwas kaputt macht muss schon verstehen was da passiert
erlernst ja auch nichts wirklich bei du darfst aber natürlich wenn du was nicht verstehst fragen
was das macht dafür finde ich das immer ganz gut kannst du raus kopieren und sagen hier erklär mal
was das macht das finde ich immer nicht nicht verkehrt genau ja das finde ich tatsächlich
nicht verkehrt
richtig deswegen würde ich einfach anfangen mit täglich linux benutzen
das ist glaube ich das einfachste was du machen kannst
täglich linux und terminal benutzen für alltägliche sachen weil dann siehst du
dich auch öfters damit konfrontiert dass irgendwie du weißt was nicht geht willst
das jetzt aber machen dann googelst du eine weile und findest was probierst es
aus wie kannst du in einer linux bash arbeiten das ist das ist zsh aber das macht es auch macht
keinen unterschied für das frage wie kannst du in einer linux bash aber gleichzeitig bis in windows
vor allem das ist ein vm ich habe mehrere desktops unter windows und auf dem zweiten desktop sieht
man hier unten wenn ich umschalte guckt desktop 2 auf dem zweiten desktop ist vor allem full screen
und das läuft ziemlich gut das ist eine ältere vor allem bei workstation version ich war bisher
zu faul zu upgraden da weiß jemand ob der kram funktioniert ja der vm habe ich ordentlich
ressourcen gegeben ich habe 80 kern und
die gleich free minus h auch und 16 24
gig ram brauchst du aber gar nicht dafür
ja ich hab ich habe zu viel ram und zu
viel cpu kerne die cdvm von mir die
brauchst du braucht nichts ja guck hier
um eine cpu auslastung nix
also das ist total auf der kill was ich
der vm gegeben habe das habe ich mitbekommen dass die linux gaming benchmarks geändert haben
was benutzt du eigentlich um deine zsh zu customizen weißt du was ich benutze zsh rc
sonst nix das ist alles das ist alles ich habe kein oh my tschisch oder sonst was und als prompt
habe ich starship das reicht auch ich finde es wird teilweise extrem übertrieben mit mit shell
customization vieles davon kannst du mit mit standard sachen machen man muss einfach nur
wissen welche konflikt man setzt ach so ja doch ich hab ich habe zwei plugins ich habe also plugins
weiß nicht ob das plugins aber das plugin sein kann ich habe auto ich habe auto suggestion und
syntax highlighting habe ich das gibt es aber als art schielungs packages da brauche ich kein
oma oder sowas auto suggestions und syntax highlighting ja also dax highlighting ist
klar hier vor in bla blub und das hier ist auto completion dass der mir den
kram anzeigt guck also das was er da hinten an zeigt sagt er okay du hast
schon mal was angefangen so was in der richtung zu tippen und jetzt kann ich
einfach hier ende drücken und dann auto komplizierte dass die zwei sachen habe
ich also ein bisschen wie in intel in intelligent ist wurde halt auch die
zeile auto komplett ganz gut wenn ich sagen l da sagt er willst du erst aus
für ja will ich dann tippt damit das schon quasi fügt er das ein das sind die
ein sie zwei plugins ich hab und die gibt es aber wenn standard package
manager brauchst kai oma oder irgendwie sowas ich finde das übertrieben ich
ganz ehrlich mir fehlt da auch nichts ich habe früher mal bretts to oder wie
das hieß verwendet vor ein paar jahren das ist so was ähnliches gewesen wie
auch mal zisch und das weiß ich also wenn man sich anguckt ich habe ich habe
jetzt hier ja auch gar nicht so viel ich habe 136 zeilen besser zsh rc so und
dass vieles davon sind irgendwelche prok alias und funktionen nicht gebaut habe
bei der wald leute warum soße ich den ich mache mit den überhaupt nichts
sozusagen keck bei den o habe ich die nur überhaupt noch installiert habe ich
gar nicht installiert aber den oen habe ich jetzt so whatever
Moment, ich hab den nur installiert
Ah, wo hab ich das denn?
Wo hab ich das denn her?
Wenn man das jetzt noch richtig schreiben könnte
Ah, ich hab den nur wohl irgendwann mal da
Lokal installiert
Ich weiß nicht warum, ehrlich gesagt
Na gut
Ansonsten hab ich in meiner ZSRC
Nix wirklich großartiges drin stehen
Ich hätte vielleicht ein paar Kommentare einfügen sollen
Dass ich heute noch weiß, was was macht
Weil das weiß ich wirklich nicht mehr.
Ich habe absolut keinen blassen Schimmer mehr, was das macht.
Ich weiß nur immer, wenn ich da was rauslöschen würde,
würde mir direkt auffallen, dass da was fehlt.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was da was macht.
Das ist das Einzige, wo mir jetzt einfällt, wo ich weiß, was es macht.
Das ist, dass dein History-File geschrieben wird, während du tippst.
Und nicht erst, wenn du deine Shell beendest.
also nach jedem befehl wird es in die history angehängt ansonsten absolut kein
plan was es macht ich glaube dass das abelt irgendwas wo man seine shell
pausieren kann das nervt dass ich mit 1 bis 9 letzten verzeichnisse durch
wechseln kann history sei es geht mittlerweile glaube ich auch anders ich
glaube man kann müsste mittlerweile gibt es eine option dass man history
unlimited machen kann braucht man gar nicht mehr dann für thema glaube ich
irgendwelche bind keys oder so was was er war irgendwas zu memory usage
kontrollieren paar alias für config files wetter wichtigste
es geht nicht mehr ist doch hier
wisse hallo leute und ein hallo koordinaten liegt
wir können die ki fragen was das macht ja so hier wetter wollen mich 50 milliarden
Wetter für Hanau und Hessen habe ich ein paar anderen Kram. Ich habe RM überschrieben,
dass RM Interactive läuft, dass ich nicht aus Versehen mein Home Verzeichnis lösche.
Zwei weitere Alias. Imagecat habe ich mal irgendwann gebastelt, um Verzeichnisse,
um Bilder aus Verzeichnis anzuzeigen
in Bash. Also es geht dann so hier.
Benutze ich eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht.
Image Cat.
So.
Wobei das eher für Verzeichnisse
gedacht ist. So, guck hier.
Image Cat.
Kann man auch SVGs in der
Bash sich angucken und so.
Das geht aber auch nur, weil
mein Terminal eben Images unterstützt.
Hast du das Krieger-Video? Das Krieger, welches denn?
Ich hoffe, dem geht's gut
Er hat abgenommen
Ey, ich hab letztens mal ein Video von ihm gesehen
Ja, da sah er viel dünner aus, nice
Richtig gut
Dass das so gut geklappt hat bei ihm
Ja, ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen, hab auch schon gedacht
Boah, der sieht aber dünn aus
Find ich aber richtig nice
Find ich cool.
50 Kilo ist schon mal eine Ansage.
Also lass mal überlegen.
Bei mir waren es nur...
Also jetzt wiege ich knapp über 80.
und ich hab mal 108 gewogen.
Also so 25, so
ja, so 25 Kilo
sind's bei mir. Aber nicht
über ein Jahr,
ähm,
sondern
über drei Jahre oder so.
Oder vier Jahre.
80, boah, krass.
Michael, 80 ist krass.
Ansonsten habe ich hier nichts weiter großartig drin in meiner ZSH erzählen.
Ne, ich finde es richtig gut, dass es beim Krieger so geklappt hat.
Manchmal ist es ja so, man weiß es eigentlich, dass es nicht gut ist.
aber man also ich merke ich kenne das ja selbst ja ich wusste auch dass es nicht
gut ist 108 kilo zu wiegen und keine ausdauer zu haben und sonst was aber ich
habe mir da immer noch nichts ich wurde also ich wusste dass es nicht gesund ist
und ich habe mir da auch immer gedacht ja ja genau das trifft das trifft
eigentlich ganz gut wenn man weiß es ist genauso wie alle raucher wissen dass
rauchen ungesund ist.
Mein Minimum war knapp unter 80.
Da ging es mir aber auch
ein paar Wochen richtig schlecht.
Ich habe wenig gegessen.
Und manchmal brauchst du dann irgendwie sowas,
was so diesen Switch macht von
man weiß eigentlich, dass es nicht gut ist
zu man hat es
wirklich
man ist wirklich auch davon überzeugt,
dass es nicht gut ist. Also man muss ja erstmal
selbst davon irgendwas überzeugt sein, dass man
was macht.
War bei mir auch so.
Ich glaube, ich bin der Einzige, der während Corona
abgenommen hat.
Alle anderen sind fetter geworden.
Ja, ich habe mit Homeoffice und Corona
irgendwie mehr abgenommen.
Seit ich aber
regelmäßig Sport mache,
habe ich gar nicht mehr so viel abgenommen.
Dafür habe ich mehr Muskeln jetzt.
Ich hab das Gewicht
So ungefähr gleich
Ja so immer 81, 82 Kilo oder so
Dafür hab ich
Mehr Muskeln gekriegt
Genau
Hast du eine Alias, um QR-Codes im Terminal zu erzeugen?
Nö.
Ich möchte gerne Kubernetes lernen und dafür mein Homelab ausbauen.
Aktuell habe ich einen alten Intel NUC.
Ja, das ist ganz gut dafür.
Habt ihr Tipps, nach welcher günstigen Gebrauchernachweis?
Wieso ist doch gut?
Du kannst den nehmen.
Nimm deinen alten Intel NUC.
Das ist vollkommen ausreichend.
Kubernetes läuft ja mal quasi auf dem Appel und Ei.
die frage ist was du dann damit laufen lässt ich kann dir aber ein tipp geben
wenn du wenn du kubernetes üben möchtest dann würde ich dir gar nicht unbedingt
so sehr ans herz legen gerade am anfang wenn man sich mit den basics
beschäftigt das ding separat auf dem intel nook drauf zu hauen weil dann
kommt wiederum die frage ja was benutzt man da wie kriegt man es drauf nimmt man
irgendwie einen OS
explizit dafür.
Habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich weiß nur, dass es... Oh, wie heißt das?
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Es gibt so ein relativ verbreitetes
OS mit
koperniertes... Dankeschön für den Sub übrigens.
Ne, nicht Flatcar.
Ähm...
Mit Read...
Talos! Talos meine ich.
genau talos der chat weiß wieder bescheid talos meine ich ja habe ich noch nie
verwendet was ich dir empfehlen würde wenn du kubernetes lernst den mini cube
weiß ja aber noch was in history haben warum habe ich das nicht mehr installiert
Das installiert ihr eine Kubernetes Control Plane.
Also sagen wir mal so, das installiert ihr Kubernetes, lässt im Endeffekt das Lokal in
Docker laufen.
Da hast du aber ein vollständiges Kubernetes und kannst damit alles mögliche ausprobieren.
Erstens auf einem Rechner der ordentlich Power hat.
Weiß ja was du darin laufen lassen willst.
Das ist natürlich nichts für 24-7 laufen lassen, sondern nur zum Üben.
Ja, aber du musst ja gerade am Anfang dich ein bisschen damit auseinandersetzen.
So, was schreibst du in deine YAML-Files rein?
Wie willst du das Ganze managen?
Wie, Cube CTL, wie das funktioniert?
Und da finde ich Minikube eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Ja, da sagst du nämlich einfach Minikube, glaub Start ist es.
Guck, zack.
schon hast du kubernetes bei dir lokal laufen
er muss einmal die neueste kubernetes version runterladen danach brauchst du
das aber nicht mehr das mini cube start
irgendwann ist er dann fertig downloaden
genau hast auch ein paar addons für den ingress und so was alles schon dabei weil
dann musste dich ja selbst kümmern wenn du kompletts aufsetzt auf dem server
genau jetzt startet er den kram und danach hast du fertig konfiguriert das cube cdl auch schon
genau so ein eigenes kloster ist cool fürs üben aber jetzt kann es auch sagen
cubectl get pods zum beispiel zack und hast dein kubernetes laufen
noch mal warten bis alles ready wird und wenn du fertig bist hast du mini cube delete und
Und dann schmeißt alles wieder weg.
Und du hast keine Reste mehr.
Also zum Üben finde ich Minikube mit Abstand das Beste.
Das ist nichts, um jetzt den produktiven Cluster laufen zu lassen.
Auch nur daheim.
Aber zum Üben ist Minikube das Beste, was es gibt.
Du hast auch Minikube Addons.
Addons List oder so.
Hast du einen Inkas zum Beispiel.
Kannst du einfach installieren.
Oder ein paar andere Dinger.
Ja, aber Inkrest ist so wahrscheinlich das, was du am ehesten brauchst.
Krass.
Das würde ich jetzt bei Minikube...
Brauche ich kein Service Mesh dabei.
Ja.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, hier.
Für Inkrest ist das ganz praktisch.
Also würde ich dir empfehlen.
guck dir mini cube an
haben die art open lenz sich jetzt so eine komische neue lizenz regelung war
da habt ihr etwas im hinterkopf
also nachdem du mit linux anfangen willst würde ich sagen installiert sind
eine vm mit einem linux deiner wahl drauf es sei denn du hast die links auf
deinem rechner ja zu den vm mit dem linux deiner wahl das benutzt du dann
auch für so tägliche arbeiten hier wie internet surfen und und sonst was also
alles was man mit die luchs gut machen kann und da kannst du dann auch gleich
mini cube drin verwenden da sind wir wieder bei der ersten frage wieder best
linux lernst einfach durch benutzen oder linux mint oder so drauf irgendwas was
schön ist für den einstieg und dann machst du da drin deine kubernetes
übung mit mit mini cube und wenn er dann sicher im handling bist kannst ja
überlegen ob die dir irgendwie das auf deinen look haust
ach so du willst du erst mal nicht platt machen
dann weiß ich nicht was was ich gerade gut anbietet an hardware keine ahnung
welche mini pc sind sind wahrscheinlich ganz nice gibt es ja schon welche recht
günstig oder irgend also wenn du also manche sagen ja auf ebay sich einen
gebrauchten server kaufen die sind billig aber sind dann auch meistens laut
und strom fressen weiß nicht ob das so sinnvoll ist
habt ihr auf der wir haben eine kantine ich gehe aber kaum noch was warmes
essen mittags in frankfurt
Was hast du eigentlich aktuell für Services in meinem Homelab?
Oh, da muss ich nachdenken.
Home Assistant ist das, was ich mit Abstand am meisten benutze.
Home Assistant, äh.
Ich habe ein paar Raspberry Pis verteilt, einen am 3D Drucker, einen im Keller.
Da müsste ich jetzt echt nachdenken.
Vieles läuft einfach so vor sich hin, wo ich gar nicht dran denke.
Also so ziemlich das einzige mit dem ich täglich interagiere ist der Home Assistant.
Ansonsten...
Ich habe halt auch vieles als Container im Home Assistant laufen.
Ich habe einen Nginx Proxy Manager für Zertifikate.
karte
wirkliches nextcloud was ich nicht mag was ich nicht verwende
da habe ich nur mal irgendwann meine meine karte auf kontakte rein und seit
dem habe ich das laut das finde ich aber will ich will das eigentlich gar nicht
mehr haben
habe ich laufend für monitoring
das fällt mir gerade nichts mehr ein
weiß jemand wie es ist bei ibm zu arbeiten zufälligerweise würde mich
auch interessieren chat wenn es doch an und ja mache ich ich bin nicht so hundertprozentig
glücklich mit android aber es ist irgendwie immer noch das beste schlechteste so home server system
was ich bisher verwendet habe sagt irgendwie alles ich verwende das hauptsächlich weil ich
zu faul bin das irgendwie umzustellen und ich auch nicht weiß worauf ich umstellen soll ich
habe das aber auch schon irgendwie seit zwei jahren nicht mehr abgegründet
also ich habe mal im stream edgar und paywall verglichen da hat mir edgar
besser gefallen ich glaube ich habe sogar auch noch
den edgar laufen für mobile mobile adblocking ich bin gar nicht mehr sicher
bin ob ich das überhaupt noch laufen habe ehrlich gesagt wahrscheinlich läuft
läuft das noch und läuft einfach vor sich hin
hier auf dem desktop verwende ich das gar nicht desktop gibt es adblocker im
browser der einfach viel besser funktioniert als dns adblocking dns
dns adblocking funktioniert an vielen stellen gar nicht mehr
aber als ich als ich mal vor zwei jahren oder so die beiden verglichen habe hat
mir edgard besser gefallen
Ja, 10 bis 15 Watt Idle geht klar.
So, dann lasst uns mal gucken, was auf
Shithub so trendet diese Woche.
Äh.
Gens.
Weekly.
Ich hab mal was trinken, Chat.
Ich hab...
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Cook like...
Hock.
Yep, Hock.
Ist das ein chinesisches Kochbuch, oder?
Was ist das hier?
Traue ich mich da drauf zu klicken?
Okay, es ist wirklich Essen.
Soll ich mal übersetzen?
Achso, Moment.
firefox hat keine translation gedürrt chrome hat aber
firefox auch aber hier chrome hat
was
ich habe so cook like homemade chicken
ich habe kein platz
Das ist ein Kochbuch oder? Fried Food.
Wingtipps.
Ja, das ist vielleicht ein sehr kurzes Rezept, oder?
Step, deep fry 6 chicken wings.
Ja gut, was auch immer.
AI.
LazyVim.
Elastic Search.
Warum trennt ihr denn ausgerechnet Elastic Search diese Woche?
Haben die irgendwie eine neue Version veröffentlicht?
Oder was ist da los?
Go Web Framework.
Irgendwelches Krypto-Zeug würde ich jetzt mal raten.
Browser.
FMT. Das Ding ist wirklich gut.
Das kann ich empfehlen.
Das ist das einzige, was so String-Handling und Formatieren und sowas in C++ erträglich macht.
FMT-Lib.
Teilweise ist das in der C++-Standard-Library.
Plus da ist es irgendwie auch wieder nur in schlecht gelandet.
Fragt mich nicht, was die da wieder getrieben haben.
webgoat ei ei ei ei
kubdo zeug vermutlich keine ahnung
kopfzeug vermutlich keiner kalt immer youtube dl youtube dl braucht jetzt angeblich habe ich
gelesen auf reddit braucht jetzt ein installiertes dino das funktioniert
das ist chill and nostalgie nintendo music to work study in the morning
2 Stunden 28
Router
Okay, diese Woche ist ja gar nichts
Spannendes dabei
Das hat er bestimmt im Titel
verkehrt geschrieben, damit Nintendo
ihn nicht strikt
hier sind wir richtig plädiert was trenne denn heute
private fast and honest honest webbrowser
Aha
Omachi trendet
Ja, das wundert mich nicht
Das gucken wir uns auch noch im Stream an
Ihr wisst jetzt schon, dass ich
Also ich weiß schon, ihr wisst wahrscheinlich auch
Ich werde es nicht verwenden
Ich bin einfach viel zu eingeschossen auf meine eigene Config
HSP.net Core trendet
Mit 8 Sternen heute
Leute, kommen wir in Trending Today rein
Wenn wir alle den Fiat Champion starren
Nee, bloß nicht, bloß nicht.
Das erzeugt ja irgendwie in meinem Hinterkopf Druck.
Ich müsste das Ding weiterentwickeln.
Jetzt wo ich das hier lese,
es treibt Semper-Video eigentlich.
Hallo hier, nur kurz gezeigt.
Ja, ASP.net Core trendet.
Mein mit Abstand Lieblings...
Backend-Web-Framework.
Online-Sachen würde ich damit nicht machen.
Fängt man gar nicht an mit Razer-Pages oder irgendeinem Müll.
Aber für Backend-Sachen, beste.
.NET 10 kommt bald.
Ja, wir gucken uns dann auch bei Release.
Das dauert wirklich nicht mehr lang.
.NET 10 Release Date.
Wir gucken uns dann auch das Ganze an.
Sobald das rauskommt.
Weil es gibt ein paar coole neue C-Sharp-
Features.
cool neues die sharp features zum beispiel dass man getter und sagt das viel jetzt neues
keyword ist extension dass du alles mögliche externe extenzieren kannst nicht nur methoden
Du kannst alles extensionen.
Extensionen kannst du.
Das sind eigentlich die zwei größten Features, die ich ganz nice finde.
Und gerade dieses Extend Anything, das hat ja schon ewig gedauert.
Das wollten die ja schon irgendwie die letzten fünf Versionen oder so bringen.
Was ich ein bisschen doof finde,
dass Microsoft was gecancelt hat für diese Version,
wo ich mich eigentlich drauf gefreut habe.
Erinnern ihr euch noch dran?
Für die, die dabei waren,
wo wir in einem der letzten Streams haben wir doch ein bisschen Java mit Spring Boot gebastelt.
Und da habe ich unter anderem die eingebaute Event-Funktion von Spring Boot ausprobiert.
Da haben wir hier gesagt, Add Event Listener und dann wird das immer aufgerufen.
Sowas gibt es in ASP.NET Core out of the box nicht.
Microsoft hat aber sowas geplant.
Oder besser gesagt, hatte sowas geplant.
Und das haben sie jetzt geclosed, weil sie irgendwie keinen Bock mehr haben.
Was ich echt doof finde, es gibt da Alternativen zu, so ist es nicht.
Aber ich fände es cool, wenn sowas auch in ASP.NET Core eingebaut wäre,
Weil das schon eine wichtige Komponente von so einem Framework ist, dass du mit unterschiedlichen Teilen der Anwendung miteinander kommunizieren kannst, ohne dass die sich direkt kennen müssen.
Ich habe auch lange nichts mehr hochgeladen, das stimmt schon.
Aber zu Battlefield 6 gibt es wieder was.
ja ja ich konnte die letzte zeit nicht so wie ich wollte
so gut dann haben wir uns angeguckt was auf github trendet kann man das wieder zu machen
hier sagt guck aufs neue package es gibt ich weiß ich habe von der viertelstunde
geupdatet aber arch by the way wie jetzt das ist da los ich habe ich habe viertel
stunde meine packages nicht geupdatet es gibt keine neuen pakete was was ist das
das ist mir nicht bleeding edge genug weil mein system nicht top aktuelles
talkst du noch ja mache ich ich spiele tatsächlich ab und zu battlefield 3 in
letzter zeit wieder so als vorbereitung auf battlefield 6
skills pdf das ist von meiner bewerbung als sich interessiert was da drin ist
da haben wir im stream die liste gemacht mit dingern von denen ich ahnung habe
und haben einfach mal alles runter geschrieben das ist nicht exakt das was
ich an meine bewerbung angehängt habe aber zu 95 prozent ist es das paar
sachen habe ich habe das noch ein bisschen schöner gemacht und paar sachen
noch ergänzt und rausgeschmissen
Manche Sachen waren auch doppelt drin und so.
Oh ja.
Huch.
Was?
Nein.
Wie um alles in der Welt kommt es jetzt drauf, dass ich YouTube an meine Taskbar pinnen möchte.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich dazu klicken muss, dass das Fenster kommt.
Du kannst Word.
Wenn du auch noch Excel kannst, dann hast du quasi die IDE der Sekretärin gemeistert.
Wie denkst du über Vivaldi? Ich finde Vivaldi ziemlich cool, aber ich benutze Vivaldi nicht.
Die BWL-IDE, genau.
Moin.
Machst du noch Teilzeit? Ja, mach ich.
Vier Tage Woche. Beste.
Wie läuft der Sport?
Ich habe in letzter Zeit ein bisschen weniger gemacht.
Ich habe zweieinhalb Monate oder so kaum was gemacht.
Ich habe jetzt vor gestern erst wieder angefangen.
Und war jetzt ein paar Tage hintereinander.
Und ich merke schon voll in den Beinen.
Ich habe gestern noch nicht mal meine normale 5,5 Kilometer Runde durchgehalten.
Da war ich nach 4,5 Kilometer oder so war der Ofen aus.
was aber auch daran lag dass ich zu dem zeitpunkt also es war 11 uhr und ich habe um 8 uhr 30 zwei
toastbrot gegessen das war einfach war einfach durch ja ich hab ich habe so nach vier kilometer
übertrieben hunger oder schon nach dreieinhalb also übertrieben hunger bekommen und wenn man
während dem rennen hunger bekommt ist das meistens ein zeichen für man kann bald nicht mehr da bin
ich die letzten paar hundert meter bin ich gelaufen top vorbereitet ich habe so
ist ein mini lebkuchen gefuttert davor
so ein kleines lebkuchen stern war das das waren aber auch nur fragt mich nicht
keine ahnung programm das hat das hat auch nicht raus gehauen
ich hatte übertrieben hunger und dann konnte ich nicht mehr
Tag davor bin ich die 5,5 Kilometer easy gerannt.
Ja, ich muss jetzt da langsam wieder anfangen.
Dann geht das auch wieder.
Ich meine, in zweieinhalb oder drei Monaten, ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich jetzt nichts gemacht habe.
Sagen wir mal einfach drei Monate.
Da ist ja nicht alles weg.
Ja, ich bin jetzt immer noch viel, viel fitter, als ich noch vor ein paar Jahren gewesen bin.
Aber das dauert jetzt mindestens wieder drei Monate, bis ich so gut bin.
Oder vielleicht zwei, drei.
Ja, gucken, bis ich wieder so gut bin wie vorher.
80% Teilzeit mache ich.
Ja, haben wir sogar im Stream schon mal verwendet.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
SystemRx.net wurde doch geforkt, oder?
Es wurde doch geforkt vor einer Weile.
Wie hieß denn das nochmal?
Das wurde geforkt.
Weil der Typ abgefuckt war von der langsamen Entwicklung und dass sich kaum noch was tut.
Forkt.
Ja, soll ich vielleicht nach, ups, nach Fortnite Reactive suchen?
Ah, R3 hieß das, genau.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das, ob das Geschwindigkeit aufgenommen hat in der Entwicklung.
Ja, also der Typ hatte das irgendwie geforkt und es scheint ja auch recht beliebt zu sein.
Ich weiß nicht, warum er das gefolgt hat.
Ich weiß nur, dass er sich drüber aufgeregt hat,
über das ursprüngliche Projekt,
das neue jetzt viel besser sein soll.
Warum fragst du?
Also wir haben im Stream das schon mal verwendet.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Ja, 80% Teilzeit ist beste.
Gibt es Neues aus dem Serverraum?
Abstellkammer
Aber Untermieter Spinnen fanden sich im letzten
Was? Ich hatte Spinnen in meinem Video?
Ne, hatte ich nicht
Wo soll ich dann eine Spinne gehabt haben in der Abstellkammer?
das muss mir jetzt sagen da muss ich mich nach guck ob die noch da ist ich mag keine spinnen
ja es gibt was neues was man noch nicht im video gesehen hat was ich aber auch schon
eben schon öfters im stream erzähler diese dieser 2h server der ist nicht mehr da da
ist jetzt ein hp microserver drin seit ein paar jahren schon überlegen das auf der arbeit zu
führen dass ich finde das sehr nice weiß aber nicht was ich aktuell anbietet das originale
oder dieser Fork, kein Schimmer.
Also ich finde das sehr praktisch.
Reactive, die haben ja noch ein anderes
Projekt, die haben Async Reactive
oder irgendwie sowas noch.
Ist auch ganz praktisch.
Können wir ein Homelab
Bastelstream machen? Was soll ich denn da machen?
Ja, für so Streams, wo du subscriben dazu willst, vielleicht filtern willst, also ich finde das nice.
Wir haben das im Stream auch schon verwendet, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher für was.
Das war auf jeden Fall irgendeine Web-Anwendung.
Ich bin mir unschlüssig für was.
Aber ich habe es mal eine Zeit lang zu allen Projekten standardmäßig hinzugefügt, weil ich es praktisch fand.
So, also lasst uns mal schauen, was können wir uns auf YouTube angucken heute.
So kämpfen junge Leute um die Gen... Gen... Gen... Gen Z.
Naja, nee, keine Ahnung.
Chat, ist überhaupt Gen Z noch angesagt?
Ist es jetzt nicht Gen Alpha eigentlich schon?
Die ganz jungen Leute
Die alle so komisch reden
Riz und Sass und sonst was
Meine Besties
Das ist doch Gen-Alpha-Slang.
Ne, Wallah sagen die nicht.
Das sagen die nur in Deutschland.
Ey, hör mal auf. Das ist so ziemlich das
Dümmste, was es gibt, Alter.
Das sind AI-generierten
Meme-Geschichten.
Das ist so dumm. Ich meine, das heißt ja nicht
umsonst Brain Rot, aber das ist wirklich
komplett, äh,
Kieren ist kaputt.
Alle, die ab 2025
geboren sind, oh, wir sind schon in Generation Beta.
Okay.
Was bin ich eigentlich 1984?
Welche Generation?
X? Bin ich X?
Ne.
Bin ich Y?
Y?
Die im Zeitraum der frühen 1980er
bis in den späten 1990er Jahren geboren wurden.
Okay.
Boah, mein Auge, Alter.
Mein Auge.
Das ist ein typisches Millennial-Bild.
Junger Vater mit Babytrage.
Okay.
Da passe ich nicht rein.
Ich bin Generation Y.
Okay, was kommt?
Nach Generation Y kommt Generation Z.
Gucken, ist das hier irgendwie...
wie gibt es nicht warum warum gibt es hier keinen link auf die auf die nächste generation
generation y am arbeitsplatz auch in bezug auf eine art generation z wikipedia
Okay, das sind Leute zwischen
und später
1997 bis 2012
Okay
Und Generation Alpha
2010 bis 2014
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt schon bei Generation Beta, oder was?
Krass.
Wann bin ich alt? Meine Güte.
Wir sind schon drei Generationen weiter, Alter.
Siehe Bilder.
wo sind hier da stimmt das war die greatest generation ok baby boomer
generation x-series wird das damit nicht
die sumas heißt in dem bild auf wirklich so
Die Zoomers.
Und hier sind die Alphas.
Die Alpha-Giga-Chats.
40% der Bahnhöfe in Hessen nicht barrierefrei.
Mich wundert es, dass es nur so wenig sind.
Ich meine, es gibt ganz viele Bahnhöfe.
Da gibt es nicht mal ein Klo.
schöne abstellkammer hat am monitor obendran schönes rack schönes rack hat er sehr ordentlich
gemacht tp link switch oder vermutlich alle ich würde sagen alle ibm hardware oder was
würdet ihr sagen?
Es hat irgendwie so ein IBM
oder das Lenovo Vibe,
finde ich.
Aber kann man schlecht sagen.
Ich würde sagen, die Hardware gibt so ein bisschen
Lenovo Vibes ab.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Der Chat hat gesagt,
das hier soll ich gucken, aber vielleicht nicht als Einstieg.
der linux experience omar ist das hier beruf mit spitzengehalt dank profession so viel verdient
ein hätte auch das kann man gucken mal gucken ob er auch was arbeitet also das schlimmste video
in der richtung was ich je bei dem channel gesehen habe ist die eine projektmanagerin
die den ganzen Tag nur Excel gemacht hat.
Oder Unternehmensberaterin, ich weiß gar nicht,
die den ganzen Tag ja nur Excel gemacht hat.
Heldhunter? Noch nie gehört.
Was macht man da? Und was vertiegt man da so?
Das war für mich unglaublich.
Okay.
Ich schäme mich nicht dafür. Ich bin eher...
Du wärst aber auch ordentlich breit, hä?
Stolz darauf, weil ich das Gehalt selbst erarbeitet habe.
Hier ist jemand.
Und ich weiß, dass die Firma auch nicht so bezahlt.
Es kann sein, dass es super läuft gerade und von einem auf den anderen Moment ist gar nichts.
Hi, ich bin Marco.
Er ist bei die Pet.
So muss das sein.
Und ich zeige euch heute meinen Tag.
Jetzt hat er angefangen.
Guten Morgen.
So, wir haben einen Tagesplan.
Unser Job.
Also, ich muss dazu sagen, ich weiß noch, wo wir, also.
als ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe, da wurden wir
ja vermietet an andere Unternehmen.
Was heißt
vermietet? Wir waren halt dort
hauptsächlich und
ich weiß, was die im Monat für uns
bezahlt haben und was wir als Gehalt bekommen
haben. Das war halt super krass, der
Unterschied.
Könnte man so ausgeliehen nennen.
Und da
ist richtig Geld drin.
Der Job ist es, Personal zu finden. Der Job ist für mich für alle eine Win-Win-Situation.
Der Kandidat freut sich, die neue Firma freut sich, der Einzige, der den kürzeren Sieg ist, der alte Arbeitgeber.
Aber der alte Arbeitgeber ist meistens selbst dran schuld, dass die Leute keinen Bock mehr drauf haben.
Ich habe eine neue Stelle bekommen, da suche ich jemanden für einen Vertriebsausdienst.
Da fangen wir erstmal an, wir werden eine Stellungszeige machen.
wir werden LinkedIn
Sync-Post fertig machen
bei der Stelle zum Beispiel das Interessante
die hat die Firma noch nicht mal offiziell ausgeschrieben
ich bin
ne, das war nicht Arbeitnehmerüberlassung
im Endeffekt, ich hab keine Ahnung
wie man das nennt, wie das da
war, wir haben fest beim Provider
gearbeitet, wir waren aber
quasi, wir hatten dort eigene Räume
in
dem Unternehmen in Frankfurt
für die wir gearbeitet haben, das war quasi so eine kleine
mini niederlassung in dem gebäude von einem anderen arbeit von einer anderen firma für
die wir das rechenzentrum und auch die etagen it räume und so betrieben haben elektronikräume und
sowas
dienstleistervertrag mit anwesend irgendwie sowas genau wenn davon geheizt marschen einfach
rein zu schreiben weil ich denke mir so warum verheimlichen weiß dass viele andere aus der
Branche leider nicht zu arbeiten. Es gibt leider in unserer Branche sehr, sehr viel schwarze Schafe.
Theoretisch kann jeder den Job machen, der ein Telefon, die ganzen LinkedIn zu Spammer und Laptop hat.
Die schreiben auch haufenweise Leute an, wo gar nichts dahinter steckt, wo die Kandidaten gar
keine Lust mehr haben mit Headhuntern zu sprechen. Das ist ein ganz, ganz großes Problem.
Am Anfang haben wir Gehälter im Jahresziel von 70.000.
Bei Vollprofis kann es bis an die 100.000 gehen.
Das Jahreszielgehalt nehmen wir als Berechnungsgrundlage.
Und dann ist es immer je nach Firma, sind es durchschnittlich ungefähr vier Monatsgehälter,
die wir ungefähr berechnen.
Das ist dann der Umsatz am Ende.
Das klingt nicht einmalig, oder?
Nee, Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Das ist
denn der Umsatz am Ende.
Das kriegen die einmalig oder wie
jetzt?
Kriege ich von dem Umsatz
ungefähr die Hälfte.
Einzigartig, woher auch
die sehr hohen Gehälter kommen.
Jetzt haben wir die Stellenanzeige fertig.
Und darauf können sich jetzt
gerne alle bewerben,
die aus dem Bereich kommen.
Natürlich können wir über
die Firmen auch direkt die Leute headhunden.
Also wir telefonieren direkt in die
Firmen rein und sprechen die Leute
proaktiv an. Wir haben unsere
Tricks und Kniffe. Was man bei diesen Jobs
immer nicht vergessen darf, ist, das
sieht immer so krass aus, so nach dem Motto
ja, hier ein bisschen Stellenanzeigen
geschaltet und schon irgendwie 17k.
Man darf aber immer nicht vergessen, von
einer erfolgreichen Vermittlung
gehen wahrscheinlich,
keine Ahnung, 30
nicht durch.
Und für die hast du ja auch Zeit und
und Aufwand reingesteckt.
An die beruflichen Nummern
der Mitarbeiter zu kommen.
Es gibt auch, dass wir in der Zentrale
anrufen und dann uns
durchstellen lassen. Da sagen wir aber auch,
wenn jemand 100% glücklich
ist, wechselt er nicht.
Jetzt haben wir gleich Meeting.
Das ist ein Austausch,
der einfach nur den Leuten helfen soll
und sich auch mal
selbst zu sehen.
Da hätte ich mich aber gewundert,
Wenn ich in meinem alten Arbeitsplatz noch hocke und auf einmal ruft mich ein Headhunter an, so random.
Die hat so viele Prozesse, ich müsste vielleicht auch mal wieder ein bisschen was machen.
Hast du nochmal nachgefragt nach weiteren Stellen?
Ja, Ende August.
Ende August. Sonst noch irgendwelche Prozesse, die...
Ach, ist das seine Firma? Nee, ist sein Team, oder?
Warum suchen die auf einmal einen Meister?
Wenn sie sagen, sie brauchen explizit einen Meister, dann fragen, warum soll es ein Meister sein?
Und wichtig, ist es ein Handwerksmeister?
Ich hätte so keinen Bock. Das ist ja, das ist nicht wirklich...
Das ist so permanent Menschenkontakt. Das wäre überhaupt kein Beruf für mich, Alter.
Oder Industriemeister.
Haben Sie jemanden geheilt gesagt?
Also es waren, ich glaube, bis 57 maximal.
Das ist viel zu wenig.
Dann muss man halt vielleicht auch nochmal mit denen sprechen, weil es ist halt einfach viel zu niedrig.
Deswegen suchen die ja auch Leute, weil die wahrscheinlich schlechte Arbeitsbedingungen haben und nichts bezahlen.
Ich suche fast Sparen.
Wenn jemand neu anfängt, wäre es schon schön, wenn derjenige im ersten halben Jahr schon ein oder vielleicht auch zwei Vermittlungen macht, um zu zeigen, er kann es.
Bei uns gibt es immer einen Leitspruch, der heißt, kannst du nicht oder willst du nicht.
Wenn du nicht kannst...
Oh nee, das klingt ja schon so nach ein bisschen Mindset.
Helfen wir dir?
Wenn du nicht willst, dann können wir dir leider nicht helfen.
Vielleicht noch erwähnenswert.
Das klingt so nach Vertriebler-Mindset-mäßig.
Sagen wir das erste, welchen man über die Zeit...
So ein DVRG-Spruch.
Immer wenn jemand vermittelt hat, dann...
Die Glocke darf nicht angefasst werden.
wenn man nicht vermittelt hat das bringt ja das ist wirklich so ein bisschen da brauchst du das
richtige mindset für das ist ja aber glücklich machen wie ein klingel foto wir haben so eine
große wort kraft wo alle mitarbeiter monka ist 60 mitarbeiter an dem tag wo ich geheiratet
habe hat ein kandidat unterschrieben mal bleiben wir mit hochzeitleiter und foto
doch das ist das richtige mindset leute ich habe gerade eine e mail bekommen von einer
firma die proaktiv auf mich geradezu kam also breiter wird vorausgesetzt jetzt wäre natürlich
interessant wie hoch soll die reisebereitschaft sein und die haben geschrieben dass die halt
schon viele Sachen gemacht haben, Stellenanzeigen, Onlinebewerbungen.
Best Case wäre, dass die sagen, zu den Konditionen, das ist es uns wert, fangt für uns an zu suchen.
Hallöchen, Steinhardt, wie macht's euch, grüß Sie.
Diese Reisebereitschaft, das wäre auch meine erste Frage, wie hoch soll die Seite?
Das ist wirklich zur Zeit das Thema, wo es einfach schwierig wird.
Die Leute haben keinen Bock.
100%
Ja, da wirst du Schwierigkeiten haben
Wie darf man sich eigentlich
eine Reisebereitschaft in Prozent
vorstellen?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen
75% und
55% Reisebereitschaft?
Ist das quasi
wie viel seiner Arbeitszeit
er nicht daheim ist?
Heißt 100%
heißt, der ist nie daheim.
Das macht doch keiner freiwillig.
Doch, es gibt immer welche, die das machen.
Aber die meisten werden das.
100% heißt,
der ist nie daheim.
Ja, das
wird schwierig, ne?
In der Alters, kannst du sagen,
älter darf der gar nicht sein für Sie?
Können Sie mich da gehaltlich abholen?
Danke, ciao.
Gehalt unklar, das ist natürlich super.
Das heißt, wir wollen einen, der alles das macht, was wir wollen, aber nichts bezahlen für.
Wird schwierig, ist halt extrem viel Reisebereitschaft.
Also wir reden von 100% Reisebereitschaft, das heißt Montag los, Freitag zurück.
Liegt jetzt ein bisschen am Gehalt, Gehalt konnte er mir gerade noch nicht sagen.
Wenn wir anfangen mit 60.000 bis zu 65.000 Euro, dann bin ich der Meinung und zuversichtlich, dass wir da jemanden finden könnten.
Ah, hier ist jemand. Der kommt genau aus der Branche, ist noch jetzt ungefähr ein Jahr fast in dem Bereich.
Ich meine, immerhin muss man ja mal sagen, der arbeitet wenigstens auch den ganzen Tag, nicht so wie andere Leute in dieser Serie.
und ich kenne auch die Firma, wo er arbeitet
und ich weiß, dass die Firma auch nicht so
bezahlt, dann
würde ich den Kandidat
direkt anrufen.
Da würde ich aber blöd gucken, wenn mich
random irgendein Typ
auf der Arbeit anruft.
Oder ruft er den jetzt auf dem Handy an?
So.
Los geht's.
Gut, das hat sich
reingegangen.
aber ist kein Problem
den merken wir uns
By the way, wir haben auf der Arbeit auch so Jabra Headsets
die Dinger sind ja echt nicht billig
aber ich mag die Dinger
überhaupt nicht
die sitzen so komisch auf dem Ohr
ich mag die überhaupt nicht
was ich auf der Arbeit benutze
mittlerweile als Headset ist
Open
Com
Das Ding benutze ich auf der Arbeit.
Das ist ein Knochenschall-Headset.
Das heißt, deine Ohren sind frei.
So sieht das aus.
Das heißt, du schreist nicht so rum.
Du hörst noch Sachen drumherum.
Das Einzige, wo es ein bisschen doof ist,
und dafür habe ich noch ein anderes Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer,
wenn mal viel Krach ist und man seine Ruhe haben will.
aber bei uns ist es eigentlich immer relativ leise im Büro.
Deswegen finde ich das gut.
Du schreist nicht so rum und du hörst noch was, was drumherum passiert.
Knochenschall
ist
vollkommen ausreichend
für Gespräche und auch
ein bisschen Musik und sowas und das Mikrofon ist auch gut.
Wir sind im Großraumbüro,
aber es ist trotzdem relativ leise.
Es ist aber auch meistens nicht voll besetzt.
Da hocken ein paar Leute drin.
Größtenteil ist leer.
Also ich,
finde ich echt super. Ich habe zwei
davon. Ich habe einmal hier eins mit
Mikro und eins ohne Mikro.
Das ohne Mikro benutze ich, wenn
ich rennen gehe draußen.
Habe ich das öfters mal auf.
Das ist halt, da habe ich es mir ursprünglich
gekauft, weil ich wollte halt
was aufziehen, wo ich unterwegs,
weißt du, wenn ich über die Straße renne,
dass ich noch höre, okay, da kommt gerade ein Auto.
Weil ich sehe viele Leute mit In-Ears
und sonst was, die kriegen halt von der Umgebung überhaupt
nichts mehr mit. Das ist halt auch kacke.
Und da sind die Dinge halt wirklich gut, weil wenn du über die Straße rennst, du guckst
halt mal kurz, aber kann dir immer noch was kommen, dann hörst du was, weil dein Ohr halt
noch frei ist.
Oder wenn ein Fahrrad von hinten klingelt oder sowas.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Ist das Toss Musik?
Ich hab einen Kumpel getroffen, mit dem ich schon klein auf Fußball zusammen gespielt
haben uns jahrelang nicht gesehen und der hat hier schon in der Firma gearbeitet, war noch im Studium,
er hat gesagt, ja ich bin Headhunter. Ich so, Headhunter? Noch nie gehört. Was macht man da und was verdient man da so?
Holt er sein Handy raus und zeigt mir eine 12.000 Euro Nettoüberweisung.
Also quasi ein bisschen wie auf YouTube, komm in die Gruppe.
Und ich dachte mir so, bitte was? Das war für mich unglaublich. Hab gesagt, okay ich mache mein Studium zu Ende und dann fange ich bei euch an.
Ja.
Jetzt bin ich fertig.
Was heißt fertig?
Fertig ist man nie.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss.
Heute ist wirklich der Wurm.
Keiner geht ran.
So.
Es ist ein Fassen.
Das regnet.
Rein, Muschi.
Wir haben Ziele, 80% Jahresziel, 90% Jahresziel, 100% Jahresziel.
Und 110% für die richtig krassen Karriere-Criner.
Zum Beispiel 80% erreichen, machen wir eine 3-Tages-Reise.
Wisst ihr, das ist der Unterschied zwischen so,
das ist ja nicht wirklich Vertrieb,
so zwischen Leute, die sowas machen und mir.
Für mich wäre das dann ein Anreiz, unter 80% zu bleiben,
weil ich will keine 3-Tages-Reise machen
mit meinen Leuten da.
Ich will meine Ruhe.
Nicht, dass ich irgendwas gegen die Leute hätte,
aber ich will meine Ruhe.
Und die feiern das wahrscheinlich alle voll.
Oder vielleicht feiert er das und seine Leute
machen halt mit, weil sie denken, dem Chef gefällt.
Also wir haben auch einmal im Jahr ein Team-Event.
Das geht immer 2 Jahre.
2 Tage.
Einmal im Jahr.
Das ist eigentlich ganz okay.
Also da habe ich schon
schlimmeres gemacht.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich immer super happy bin, wenn das ist.
Ich habe da immer am Anfang keinen Bock.
Aber wenn es dann erstmal losgegangen ist,
dann geht's.
Da waren wir schon
in Mykonos, Ibiza.
Da sind schon
die ein oder anderen...
Ich kann
immerhin auf Griechisch ein bisschen schimpfen.
Das Einzige, was ich auf Griechisch kann.
Spitzdame wie Bakani während es da entstanden.
Das ist doch nicht dreisen.
Also, ist doch mal ein anderes, aber ist schön.
Hilfe!
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das ist.
Unbekannte Nummer.
Steinhardt von der Topstep.
Richtig, danke für den Rückruf. Ich hatte sie angerufen, ich hatte ihr Profil auf StepStone gesehen und hatte gesehen, dass sie im Bereich der USV-Notstromtechnik unterwegs sind. Kurz zu mir, ich bin Headhunter.
Es geht Ihnen nur darum, Sie wollen gerne jeden Abend zu Hause sein, wenn es möglich ist.
Ja, das kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Ne gut, dann weiß ich Bescheid.
Dann würde ich sagen, ich würde mich melden,
wenn ich mehr weiß und dann sprechen wir nochmal.
Danke Ihnen.
Ciao. Ich gehe mal davon aus, die haben
ihn gefragt,
ob das okay ist,
wenn man das sendet.
Ja.
Wirklich.
Und jetzt würde ich dann wahrscheinlich nachher oder morgen einmal alle Firmen abtelefonieren,
sagen, ey, hör zu, ich habe hier jemanden.
Und dann schauen wir mal, was sie dazu sagen.
Ich muss noch Urlaub genehmigen, weil die Mitarbeiter, die stellen ja bei mir auch die Urlaubsanträge.
Das ist aber nicht das richtige Karriere-Crying-Set-Mindset.
Also Urlaub war...
Man muss erst mal auf LinkedIn posten, warum man freiwillig auf seinen Urlaub verzichtet und warum das eine gute Sache ist.
Das ist das richtige Karrieremindset.
Ich würde sagen, das erste Jahr fast gar nicht.
Also es war wirklich so gut wie gar nicht.
Und Urlaub heißt auch nicht Urlaub.
Urlaub heißt trotzdem immer erreichbar.
Immer E-Mails beantworten.
In der Primetime, sprich Anfang des Jahres, Ende des Jahres, 50, 60 Stunden, Wochen normal.
Also komplett normal.
Dann gibt es aber die Sommerzeit, wie jetzt zum Beispiel, wo wir auch einfach mal ein bisschen entspannter machen können.
Wo es eher sich beinahe 45 Stunden Woche entspannt.
45 Stunden Woche vielleicht einpendelt.
Also das ist jetzt ein Call, da war ein Kandidat, waren Interviews.
Und jetzt steht es kurz vor Vertragsvorlage oder es wird noch entschieden, ob der Kandidat überhaupt genommen wird.
Und jetzt werden wir das wahrscheinlich besprechen.
Es gibt wirklich Projekte, da sind es 10, 15 Telefonate.
Und dann gibt es Projekte, da sind es 300 Telefonate.
An dem Projekt sind wir fast ein Jahr dran.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, worum es geht.
Ich würde nur um ein Gespräch gebeten.
Und jetzt schauen wir einfach mal.
Ich hoffe, darum geht es, dass wir das Ganze besprechen können.
Und gucken einfach mal, was dabei rauskommt.
einen wunderschönen guten tag ihr habt jetzt bestimmt heute auch mal gesprochen
wegen den wenn wir krank sind wenn wir in urlaub sind wir verdienen da musste
man chat da müsst ihr mal
warum habe ich hier keinen chat zugemacht ich kack noob
Der Lebensinhalt von den Leuten da ist 6000 Euro Sparrate.
Und dann auf Reddit Finanzen posten.
Kein aktives Geld.
Es kann sein, dass es super läuft gerade und von einem auf den anderen Moment ist gar nichts.
Ein ganz, ganz großer Antrieb ist Angst bei mir.
Hört sich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen doof an.
Aber Angst, den Standard, den wir jetzt leben oder diesen Traum, den wir gerade leben, ich und meine Familie mit meinen tollen Kindern, meiner tollen Frau, dass wir das einfach irgendwann verlieren könnten.
Das heißt, du stehst permanent den ganzen Tag unter Strom?
Ja, wenn ihr sagt, das ist der einzige Weg, dann machen wir das so.
Ja, war jetzt nicht ganz so wie erhofft, war aber was ich mir auch hätte denken können.
Der Geschäftsführer ist noch nicht ganz überzeugt von dem Kandidaten.
Wir kriegen für Stellen hohe Positionen, aber ja, es steckt da 28 Leute vorgestellt.
Naja, das ist halt das, was ich meine.
Die stecken da sau viel Zeit und Energie rein, aber wenn die dann sagen, machen wir nicht,
Dann war das alles umsonst und kriegst nicht bezahlt.
Dann waren schon 15, 16 Leute im Interview drinne.
Wir haben jedes Interview koordiniert, wir haben jedes Mal Feedbackgespräche vorher,
nachher, Vorbereitungen für 16 Kandidaten gemacht.
Alles.
Es gibt Monate, da krieg ich mein Grundgehalt von 2300 Euro.
Es gibt halt andere Monate, da sind es dann teilweise 50.000 Euro in einem Monat brutto.
Wir ziehen durch und wir werden den Kandidaten finden und wir werden auch diese Stelle besetzen.
Hallöchen!
Ja gut, dann musst du es halt liefern, ne?
Sonst gibt es keine Kohle.
Hallöchen, ich grüße Sie.
Oh Baby!
Im letzten Jahr habe ich 267.000 Euro brutto verdient.
Das sind ungefähr 22.200 Euro brutto und ungefähr 13.600 Euro netto jeden Monat.
In der Firma vergleichsweise bin ich unter den Top-Performern.
Durchschnittsgehälter sind von 70.000 bis 80.000 Euro.
Und dann geht es aber auch natürlich sehr schnell hoch, aber auch natürlich sehr schnell runter.
und sich ein guter tag gewesen würde ich sagen aber ja ist wieder viel arbeit für
die nächsten tage muss erst mal die hälfte steuern bezahlt sagt halde
jetzt geht's nach königs wusterhausen
nach wohnen königs wursthausen da gibt schon geile stadt namen habe ich eine wohnung kauft
zwei zimmer 60 quadratmeter der ist headhunter vermittelt jobs oder wie nennt man das stellen
sucht leute die zu stellen passen offen stellen ich will was hinterlassen habt ihr gesagt okay
Ich kaufe immer mehr Immobilien und alle meine Immobilien rechnen sich fast von alleine.
Das ist halt das richtige Crylizern-Mindset.
Dosen anbringen und einen Lichtschalter anbringen.
Das ist doch krass, in seinen zwei Stunden Freizeit kümmert er sich dann auch um elf Wohnungen.
Also Wohnzimmer komplett.
Ja, da geht mit 45 in Rente dann.
Ja, länger hältst du das wahrscheinlich auch dann aus.
Neue Küche mit allem drum und dran.
Schlafzimmer.
Das Highlight von mir
ist das Bad.
Der hat noch gefehlt.
Die Immobilien, an denen verdiene ich
zur Zeit. Das kann halt auch nicht jeder machen, muss man mal ehrlich
sagen, ja.
Da musst du
quasi an
nichts anderes denken.
Die Zeit ist theoretisch noch gar nichts. Der Cashflow ist zurzeit ungefähr 1000 Euro minus.
Was für mich aber auch gar nicht schlimm ist, weil ich auf lange Sicht das Ganze sehe.
Mein Ziel ist es, mal 50 Wohnanhalten zu haben.
Und dann nach 10 Jahren jedes Jahr immer 2 bis 3 Stück zu verkaufen, im besten Fall steuerfrei.
Und dann auch beim Super.
Nein, nein. Ich bleibe in meinem schönen Malo.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Kann er das nicht richtig aussprechen?
Chico?
Aber danke schön für deine
Subscription.
Schon immer
mein Riesentraum. Ich wollte schon immer
zwei Kinder haben. Ich wollte immer eine
tolle Frau haben. Mein Haus,
meine Garage.
Der R8 war schon immer so ein Kindheitstraum.
Meine Katze hieß übrigens auch Chico.
Wieder unten rechts.
Ich hätte nie in meinem Leben gedacht, dass ich mir jemals sowas leisten kann.
Tja, David, der Karriere-Crime läuft bei ihm.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Ich muss mal kurz ausmachen.
Es war schon zu viel Toss-Musik in diesem...
Hey, immer noch? Meine Güte.
Das hört nicht auf.
Hallo.
Wohnzimmer.
Mit Kamin.
Kamin ist so crazy teuer.
Ja.
Mit der Kohle musst du ja auch was machen, ne?
Und große Küche.
Wollen wir rausgehen Fußball spielen?
Alter, wie viel Tossmusik läuft da eigentlich diesmal?
Ist ja schlimm.
Finanziell gesehen ist es nicht die schlauste Entscheidung in Eigenheim, gerade wenn man
aus der Investment-Richtung guckt.
Einfach fürs Gewissen und sowas ist es schon schön.
Man hat seine eigenen vier Wände, da werden seine Kinder groß, egal was passiert.
Essen!
Ohne meine Frau wäre das alles nicht möglich.
Sie hält mir komplett den Rücken frei, ist die tollste Mutter,
die ich mir vorstelle für meine Kinder.
Es tut mir auch manchmal echt weh, wenn ich morgens zur Arbeit gehe,
so spät abends nach Hause komme, dass die Kinder schon schlafen
und ich die Kinder nicht sehen kann.
Aber ja, ich weiß, für was ich es mache.
Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Er hat bestimmt ein Fitnessstudio daheim.
Ja, das ist halt eine andere,
weiß nicht, wie soll man sowas nennen,
Lebenseinstellung.
Für mich wäre das nix.
Das hat halt so ein bisschen
komm in die Gruppe, du musst hustlen,
Vibes.
Aber für manche Leute ist das was.
Und dass es sich lohnen kann, sieht man ja.
Ich habe einfach nicht das Mindset dafür.
Genau, so ist es. So sieht es aus.
Ich habe nicht das Mindset.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich jemals das Mindset für sowas haben werde.
Bei mir geht es eher darum, noch weniger zu arbeiten irgendwann.
Und ich meine, ich kriege ja auch schon ein wenig Kohle.
Aber weit davon entfernt.
der verdient das doppelte
also was sie da hatten
wenn ich 100% arbeiten würde
und rufbereit schaffen alles
habe ich die Hälfte von ihm
also das ist schon mal eine andere Hausnummer
da
und ich gehe ja nicht 100% arbeiten
Kannst du nicht oder willst du nicht?
Beides.
Ich will nicht und ich könnte es wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Muss jeder selbst wissen.
Da ist der Krieger ja am Start.
Ach, er nimmt Monjaro.
Ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit hat das auch mal genommen.
Und hatte dann nach...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das erzählen darf.
Und hatte dann irgendwie nach zwei Wochen übelst krasse Verstopfung.
Und konnte irgendwie fünf Tage oder so nicht mehr aufs Klo.
Und dann hat er aufgehört, es zu nehmen.
Ah, der Krieger sieht wirklich gut aus jetzt hier.
Voll, voll, voll schlank, ne?
Hallo, herzlich willkommen.
Guck mal.
Richtig nice.
Ab 50 Kilo sind halt auch 50 Kilo, ne?
S.
Remote Software.
Moment, ist das nicht der Typ, der 24-7 arbeitet, von dem wir schon mal was geguckt haben?
der 24 7 on call bei google ist das ein anderer da hatten wir haben noch mal
einen der irgendwie gefühlt immer on call war
hast du den ich war habe ich nicht ich wüsste auch nicht wieder normal
ausgesehen hat also keine ahnung gab es nicht mal eine cat cam gab es nicht es
gab manchmal in youtube videos gab es paar katzen
ich habe auch gerade gar keine katze ich kann könnte gar keine cat cam machen
Wenn es so ein Hubi Keys, also ich privat nicht auf der Arbeit haben wir welche.
Wobei ich mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher bin, ob das Hubi Keys sind, aber es sind halt so Sticks, wo du drauf drückst.
So USB Sticks zum drauf drücken und entsperren.
Weiß nicht genau, ob das YubiKeys sind.
Doch, ich glaube, das sind YubiKeys.
So ganz kleine USB-C-Dinger.
Ja.
So, was haben wir denn noch hier?
Was ist das denn?
Oh ne, das ist bestimmt cringe, oder?
Mit Linux-Ballfell...
Okay, das gucken wir mal ganz im Schnelldurchlauf.
Das kann ich...
Da habe ich wahrscheinlich alle zwei Minuten was zu meckern.
I hate JavaScript.
Das wollte ich auch noch gucken.
Ne, das nicht.
Mit Linux-Ballfell das ablösen.
Okay.
Ich weiß, dass ich bei solchen Videos immer viel zu meckern habe.
Das...
Das wird schlimm.
Ja, aber gut, bis auf die Games, die gar nicht laufen, ne?
Doch, Anti-Cheat.
Ne, Anti-Cheat.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das Video aushalte.
So ein großer Windows-Fanboy.
Meinst du mich? Ja.
Ich bin Chat.
Es ist ja bekannt, dass ich der allergrößte Windows-Fanboy überhaupt bin.
Ein großer player in der es gibt. Ah wie anti cheat jetzt
So gut dass die seite muss schon mal angucken
Ich muss windows breit
Problem ja
Ein großteil von zeit nicht
Gibt es schon Battlefield 6 Einträge?
Warum ist 1942 auf Linux denn broken?
What the fuck?
Das hätte ich gerne, das ist das, was mit Sicherheit läuft.
Battlefield 6 geht natürlich nicht
Tja
Das ist halt so, das ist eines der größten Dinger
Was Linux Gaming
und ein bisschen den Strich durch die Rechnung macht, wenn man Games mit Anti-Cheat spielen will.
Für alles andere ist das zum großen Teil ja mittlerweile fein.
Ja, gerade unter Linux muss man aber auch, warte mal, wo ist der hier?
Gerade unter Linux ist es halt auch so, man darf da nicht rangehen mit,
es ist ja quasi nur Windows ohne die Windows-Eigenheiten,
sondern es ist halt was komplett anderes, eigenes.
mit einem gescheiten Terminal und einer gescheiten
Shell, gerade wenn man Windows-Benutzer
war und dort noch
CMD und Batch
kennt, den Schrott will ja niemand
verwenden im Terminal,
aber das ist halt unter Niedungs viel besser.
Deswegen hat man da am Anfang
ein bisschen Berührungsängste mit, weil man sich denkt,
das ist sicherlich genauso Schrott wie unter Windows,
ist es aber nicht.
Ich benutze auf der Arbeit auch ein Windows-Notebook.
Weißt du warum?
weil ich muss nicht weil ich will
gemeinde aber vor nicht allzu langer zeit wieso macht denen eigentlich
niemand konkurrenz dieser player war nerv und neben der größten spielplattform
der welt hat steam gaben war am start auch die zukunft des betriebssystems für
gamer entwickelt proton na ja eigentlich stimmt das nicht so ganz denn das betriebssystem an sich
war schon seit 1991 da bisher kennt man es aber eigentlich nur von servern oder raspberry pi ist
und hält sie oder android da kennt man es auch wobei da ja der streit recht groß ist ist android
eine Linux-Distribution oder nicht?
Gibt es Leute, die sagen so und es gibt Leute,
die sagen so.
Ich habe dazu keine fundierte
Meinung. Ich kann dazu nichts sagen.
Charts mit 150%?
Ja gut, kann ja durchaus sein,
dass einfach zwei Sachen verwendet werden.
Guck, ich benutze auch Windows und Linux.
Also ich müsste auch beides ankreuzen.
Guck, hier Windows, hier Linux.
Windows, Linux, Windows, Linux.
...sich aus Respekt vor der einschüchternden Komplexität
lieber fern davon.
Linux ist nur was für IT-Nerds.
Alle IT-Nerds schreien jetzt,
nein, nein, das kann jeder benutzen,
das ist gar nicht so schwer.
Und wir halten weiterhin Abstand,
weil wie kann man jemals...
Ganz ehrlich, die übelsten Kack-Noobs sind auch zu doof, Windows zu installieren.
...einem IT-Nerd glauben, wenn er sagt, etwas ist nicht kompliziert,
während er jeden Befehl, den wir mit Mausklicks machen,
als separaten Befehl in eine Konsole eintippen muss.
Ja, weil es besser ist unter Linux als unter Windows.
Mach mal Netzwerk-Config unter Windows per CLI
und mach mal Netzwerk-Config unter Linux per CLI.
Das ist einfach Gewöhnungssache.
Mein Vater benutzt auch Linux Mint jetzt seit zwei Jahren oder so.
Und das geht einfach.
Ich muss da nie was machen. Das tut einfach.
Und mein Vater ist der übelste Noob.
Der hat absolut keinen Plan.
Ganz entspannt wie bei der Konkurrenz. War nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis das irgendein Konzern verstehen wird, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber wieso genau passiert denn das jetzt erst?
Über Jahrzehnte war Gaming und Windows komplett selbstverständlich und nicht in Frage zu stellen.
Alter, was ist das für Musik im Hintergrund? Also passiert jetzt gleich irgendwas?
Wenn man am PC spielen wollte, war Microsofts System alternativlos.
Spiele unter Linux, das war irgendwie eher mit vielen Kopfschmerzen möglich,
aber im Endeffekt war das Hauptproblem zusammengefasst simpel.
Bisschen Kopfschmerzen ist ja immer noch.
Denn so ziemlich niemand...
Gerade Nvidia-Grafikkarten sind jetzt ja unter Linux auch so ein Ding, ne?
...hat bisher Treiber für Linux berücksichtigt, weil der Markt so verschwindend klein war,
dass es sich eben nicht wirklich ausgezahlt hätte.
Chat, ist das immer noch so?
immer noch so dass Nvidia Treiber unter Linux Shit sind?
Ist das schon wieder so lang her?
Ist das wirklich schon wieder drei Jahre her,
wo das Steam Deck rausgekommen ist?
Die perfekte Arch Linux, by the way.
Linux aber richtig nervig, benutzerunfreundlich ist, war die Herausforderung, es benutzerfreundlicher zu machen.
Und dafür hat Valve Proton entwickelt.
Beziehungsweise nicht direkt entwickelt, aber sehr...
Ist doch Arch-based, oder? SteamOS.
...wohl finanziert.
Relativ sicher.
Das ist im Großen und Ganzen ein Tool, das es schafft, Spiele, die nur Windows-Treiber haben, in Linux auch zum Laufen zu bringen.
Ja, und das Lächerliche dran ist halt, dass die dann teilweise richtig krass viel besser laufen als in Windows.
was vor ein paar jahren unvorstellbar war ist heute nicht mal nur ein traum
mit potenzial sondern komplette realität ist ja was ich manchmal frage ich spiele
nicht unter linux weil ich habe hier ja noch in windows
ich frage mich liegt die bessere performance unter linux
vielleicht auch daran dass manche sachen unter linux nicht supportet werden oder
manche Sachen nicht richtig funktionieren
und es deswegen schneller läuft,
weil halt manche Sachen geskippt werden, irgendwie.
Oder es liegt einfach
wirklich daran, dass bei Windows so viel Shit im Hintergrund
läuft.
Oder manche Sachen einfach
besser unter Linux durchdacht sind.
Ja, weil wenn du hier
Windows Prozessmanager
aufmachst, da hast du ja bei einer Windows
11 Installation, hast du ja erstmal
irgendwie 50 stinger im hintergrund laufen
luchs löst windows im gaming segment ab schon 2023 liefen 83 der 100 meist
gespielten steam titel auf dem steam deck oder auf desktop linux und das
wachstum hört auch nicht auf bis mai 2025 ist der liebste wisst ihr was ich
gut daran finde,
dass es eventuell
die Verbreitung langsam
steigert, dadurch, dass halt
sagen wir mal, alles ganz gut geht
oder sagen wir mal, 80%
ganz gut geht, außer die
Anti-Cheat-Spiele
und dass es immer weiter steigt, immer weiter
steigt, nicht jeder spielt Spiele
mit Anti-Cheat und sowas, ja, immer weiter steigt,
immer weiter steigt. Leider sind halt die Spiele
mit Anti-Cheat auch eine der
verbreitetsten, aber
immer weiter steigt, immer weiter steigt,
Bis dann vielleicht irgendwann die Hersteller auf die Idee kommen, langsam auch mal für die Sachen, wo es jetzt noch nicht geht, Linux Support einzubauen. Das kann auf jeden Fall unterm Strich für uns nur gut sein.
Linux-Marktanteil auf 2,7% unter Steam-Nutzern gewachsen.
Ja, okay, 2,7%.
Wir haben das vielleicht etwas größer klingen lassen jetzt.
Aber ihr müsst euch denken,
im Vergleich zu den mickrigen Bruchteilen eines Prozents
vor ein paar Jahren ist das eine absolute Sensation.
Und im Jahr 2025 ist dann alles komplett klar geworden.
Lenovo...
Im Jahr 2025 benutzt sogar PewDiePie Arch, by the way.
bringt eine Handheld-Gaming-Konsole raus.
Einmal mit Windows und einmal mit SteamOS.
Die Hardware ist die exakt gleiche.
Der Output der gleichen Hardware ist aber, naja, gravierend unterschiedlich.
Die Performance von Spielen ist auf SteamOS in allen Belangen um 5-15% besser.
Einfach generell.
Aber als wäre das nicht schon klar genug, habt ihr teilweise abhängig vom Spiel
einfach 50% geringere Akkulaufzeit.
Nur wegen Windows.
50 Prozent!
Naja, früher war das oft umgedreht.
Die Akkuleistung unter Windows war deutlich besser als unter Linux.
Auf vielen Notebooks.
Zwei Stunden Hades ist das Ding aus und SteamOS läuft nochmal zwei Stunden.
Das ist crazy.
Das ist nicht mal alles, sondern einfach nur, was uns so richtig überzeugt hat.
Aber wenn ihr wirklich alle Vorurteile wissen wollt, seht euch mal dieses Video hier an.
Richtig fad hat das Ganze aufgenommen, als im April 2025 dann PewDiePie,
Der PewDiePie mit über 110 Millionen Abonnenten, der ehemals größte YouTuber überhaupt, ein Video veröffentlicht hat mit dem folgenden Titel.
I installed Linux, so should you.
Das Video ist ein Windows-Rant und er kritisiert Windows für alles, was eben Kacke dran ist.
Zwangsupdates, immer mehr Eingriffe in die Nutzerfreiheit, Hardware-Hürden ab Windows 11.
Er meint, genug ist genug.
Und außerdem ist Windows mittlerweile so ein krasses Stückwerk aus allem Möglichen.
Das ist ja gar kein zusammenhängendes Betriebssystem mehr so richtig.
Das ist ganz wild.
Und Microsoft steckt da gefühlt auch keiner der Arbeit mehr rein, um das besser zu machen.
Hook, Linux und Linux Gaming trennten als Suchanfrage die Tage darauf.
Timing? Perfekt fast schon. Zu perfekt.
Denn Windows 10 wird bald abgedreht und Windows 11 stellt viele User mit alter Hardware vor die Wahl.
anderes Betriebssystem oder neue Hardware.
Oder beides. Beides geht auch.
Bisher konnten Leute nicht so einfach weg von Windows,
aber Steam hat das mit deren Erfindung komplett geändert.
Das Herzstück ist, wie schon vorhin erwähnt, Proton.
Inkompliziert ist Proton eine Kompatibilitätsschicht,
die Windows-APIs automatisch auf die Grafik-Schnittstelle Vulkan übersetzt.
In einer Sprache, die wir Windows-Nutzer verstehen,
heißt das, die meisten Windows-Spiele laufen einfach.
Manche gleich gut wie vorher und sehr viele sogar deutlich besser.
Das Paradebeispiel dafür ist Elden Ring.
2022 noch ein Stutterfest für Windows-Nutzer.
Shader-Stuttering, um genau zu sein.
Valve hat mit einem Easy-Hotfix im Steam-OS alles sofort unter Kontrolle gebracht.
Windows hatte da deutlich größere Probleme.
Aber das Ergebnis aus Sicht des Gamers, auf Linux läuft das Spiel flüssig.
Alter, die Musik im Ender-Console.
Gleich kommt ein super krasser Reveal.
Und auf Windows nicht.
Wer übrigens nicht weiß, was Shader-Stuttering ist,
es ist ein spürbares Rucken oder Einfrieren im Spiel,
das entsteht, wenn Grafikeffekte und Betriebssystem
nicht so ganz die gleiche Sprache sprechen.
Hä? Das macht keinen Sinn.
Es entstehen natürlich immer mehr Berichte drüber,
dass das Game in Linux viel besser läuft.
Manche richten Dual-Boot-Systeme ein.
Andere schmeißen Windows gleich.
Geh mal bloß weg.
Ich hab auch keine Ahnung,
was Microsoft da treibt.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel
für wie
verkackt oder wie
zerstückelt
Windows ist, ist mein Lieblingsding,
was ich immer zeige. Also erst mal
dieses hässliche Menü hier, das fängt ja schon an,
aber das will ich gar nicht zeigen.
Properties, Customize,
Change Icon.
Das ist, das ist, die Dinger
sind straight, teilweise
aus Windows 3.11.
Null und Secure Boot und führt
Virtualization Based Security ein.
Ja, müsst ihr jetzt nicht alles
checken, aber wisst ihr, was das alles macht?
Es kostet euch wertvolle FPS und bringt euch keinen Vorteil.
Dass diese Sache übrigens von Valve so sehr gefördert und entwickelt wurde,
ist keine wirklich große Überraschung, wie manche vielleicht denken.
Valve-Chef Gabe Newell hat schon 2013 gesagt,
Linux and Open Source are the future of gaming.
Ja gut, Gaben sagt das natürlich auch nicht ganz ohne Hintergedanken,
aber es wäre schön, wenn es so wäre oder so wird.
Natürlich ist er von den Nerds damals schon für so einen Spruch geliebt worden
und für alle anderen hat das einfach nur das Vertrauen in seine Kompetenz als Gaming-IT-Overlord bestätigt.
Niemand hat es als Ankündigung für irgendetwas gesehen, aber scheinbar war es nicht nur sinnloses Dahergerede.
Wir sollten Gaben vielleicht öfter mal genauer zuhören.
Auch Tim Sweeney, CEO von Epic Games, hat das Steam Deck als Amazing Move bezeichnet, wenn auch mit Einschränkungen.
Ja, gut.
Hatten die nicht großen Stress?
Mit
schon mit App-Stores und sowas?
Hat er so am Rande damit zu tun?
Gibt es eigentlich Fortnite wieder unter iOS jetzt?
Fortnite bleibt aus Anti-Cheat-Gründen
trotzdem erstmal draußen.
Auch die Influencer-Szene spielt mit.
Nicht weil Valve ihnen Geld zahlt,
sondern weil sie ganz einfach wirklich die bestmöglichen Moves machen.
Neben PewDiePie hat zum Beispiel Linus Tech Tips oder Jace Two Cents ausführliche Langzeittests für Linux gemacht
und das Fazit war verdammt eindeutig.
Es ist offiziell, Linux ist nicht mehr nur für Hacker und IT-Elite.
Für Publisher heißt das, minimalst mehr Reichweite für deutlich mehr Aufwand.
Das passt noch nicht zusammen.
Spiele müssen auf zusätzlichen Plattformen getestet und optimiert werden.
Na gut, aufs Optimieren wird ja heutzutage prinzipiell verzichtet, habe ich den Eindruck.
Gleichzeitig eröffnet sich ein neuer Markt, wo jeder von Anfang an dabei sein will,
weil einfach alles dafür spricht, dass er den Windows-Pfad überlegen ist. Nur die Nutzerzahlen,
die spiegeln das nicht so ganz wieder noch. Für uns Gamer heißt es aber schon jetzt,
echte Wahlfreiheit. Keine Abhängigkeit von Microsoft. Wer sich an den Übergang von DOS
zu Windows erinnert, der kann von Glück reden,
dass sein Gedächtnis in so einem fortgeschrittenen Alter
noch so topf ist.
Ey, von den Leuten, die das gucken, erinnert sich doch keiner,
aber ein Übergang von DOS zu Windows, Alter.
Und erkennen vielleicht auch ein Muster.
Sobald eine offene Plattform,
so wie Linux sie ist,
genügend Komfort bietet,
geraten geschlossene Systeme,
so wie Windows, es ist enorm unter Druck.
2025 könnte tatsächlich
als das Jahr in die Geschichte eingehen,
in dem Linux für Gamer
Ihr habt ja auch mitgemacht.
Das heißt, ihr seid noch älter als ich, ja?
Ich bin 41.
Und ich hab das nicht richtig mitgekriegt.
Ah, ja, ja, Chat.
Aber eins ist klar, nicht allzu langer Zeit werden verdammt viele von euch beim Starten vom PC kein Windows-Logo mehr sehen, sondern Linux starten.
Wie geht's euch mit diesem Gedanken, dass ihr vielleicht schon bald zum Linux-User werdet?
Oder seid ihr es vielleicht schon?
Erzählt es uns gerne in den Kommentaren oder auch auf unserem Discord.
Und bevor wir jetzt komplett raus sind, noch eine absolut versteckte Geheimfrage an die treuesten Mitglieder unserer Community.
Wir wollen rebranden. Hit oder Shit, das tut es irgendwie nicht mehr so ganz.
Wir wollen einen neuen Namen und einen neuen Look.
Wenn ihr Vorschläge habt, wie dieser Channel in Zukunft heißen könnte, bitte inspiriert uns gerne in den Kommentaren oder auch auf Discord.
Das ist mir eigentlich wurscht.
Hitschit.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Stimme fake ist.
Dazu hat es viel zu gut gepasst, was erzählt wurde und wie man sich das Kamerabild gesehen hat und sowas.
Das hört sich einfach nach krassem Soundkompressor an.
Was für ein OS Setup benutzt du im Moment genau?
Windows 11?
Also als Hausbetriebssystem Windows 11?
Spielst du noch Cod?
Oh, ich habe schon lange kein Cod mehr gespielt.
die letzten Teile haben mich so überhaupt nicht
geschockt
das letzte Mal wo ich wirklich
länger Call of Duty gespielt hab
war als Warzone relativ neu war
aber
dann hatte ich auch irgendwann keinen Bock mehr
ja also ich benutze Windows
als Hausbetriebssystem und dann habe ich hier
Arch Linux
by the way in der vm laufen auf dem zweiten desktop guckt deswegen kann ich linux und
windows so ohne weiteres hier switchen der fabian wird kein battlefield spielen aber ich bin sicher
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Ich muss mal kurz Nass putzen.
Was für ein Virtualisierung-Software benutze ich?
Das ist Forever Workstation.
Beste.
Angeblich ist Forever Workstation sogar mittlerweile kostenlos.
War da nicht was?
nutzt du in deinem arbeitsalltag eigentlich reguläre ausdrücke ja
wenn man irgendwas kreppen muss ja hier bla bla e grepp da musste ja manchmal
sagen ihr fängt an mit lull oder so was es nicht macht aber
aber ich habe ist moment da was ist das das kenne ich ja noch gar nicht soll
man nicht mal verwenden es ist krepp krepp minus
dass wir jetzt ist er in der tat neu ja du willst ja manchmal sachen sagen wie
fängt mit L an,
dann kommt irgendwas und dann kommt Max
oder so, ja, also,
es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich täglich mir
irgendwelche langen Regexes aus den Fingern sauge,
aber sowas in diesem Ausmaß
kommt öfters vor.
Nutzt du privat 100% Linux,
wenn du keine Anti-Cheat-Games spielst?
Ne, ich spiele alles unter Windows,
weil ich hab ja
Linux in der VM laufen und Gaming
in der VM funktioniert richtig.
Dann bräuchte ich ja noch quasi einen Dual-Boot
für linux und macht für mich keinen sinn weil ich kann ohne probleme unter windows
spielen und alles andere unter linux machen warum soll ich mir dann tool boot geben
ja ich glaube ich logisch
wie wäre es mit android als betriebssystem wie auf desktop
Nee.
Nix Package.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir den schon mal ausprobiert haben.
Also ich habe ihn schon mal ausprobiert.
Ohne euch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir ihn im Stream schon mal ausprobiert haben.
Nee, WSL habe ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr ausprobiert.
Da habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Welches Linux würdest du empfehlen,
wenn man langsamer sicher von windows weg will und das nur noch für gaming nutzt ehrlich gesagt
habe ich da keine first oder keine erfahrung aus erster hand weil ich halt selbst unter
linux nicht spiele was ich gehört habe ist das cash ios voll nice sein soll nur spielen ansonsten
ist zum einstieg linux mint nicht verkehrt so als kann man kann man
eigentlich immer verwenden wie gut das für gaming ist keine ahnung
aber cash ios ist zurzeit angesagt was linux gaming angeht
KashiOS ist Nummer 1 auf Distrowatch.
Ja, Distrowatch ist halt Kekwait.
Distrowatch kannst du halt knicken.
aber das ist aber unterstreicht vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen dass es zurzeit sehr angesagt ist
jetzt was besseres nicht wirklich der mx linux habe ich ausbringt habe ich nie verstanden warum
warum das so beliebt ist.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich CacheOS
empfehlen,
wenn ich davon Ahnung hätte,
weil ich habe noch nie einen
Gaming Linux ausprobiert.
Vielleicht ist es mal an der Zeit, Leute.
Vielleicht sollten wir... Ich habe hier ja noch
so ein Mini-PC stehen
mit AMD-Grafikkarte
und sonst was drin. Also was, was ich eigentlich
gut eignen sollte
für Linux. Vielleicht sollten wir
da mal im Stream
CacheOS.
Guck mal!
Ist sogar schon geplant.
Mal gucken, ob das irgendwann
noch stattfindet.
Meine Streaming-Themenliste
wird ja eher immer mehr als weniger.
Omachi probieren wir
in der VM. Ich probiere es nämlich
aus dem Grund aus der VM,
weil
das ist ja
Wayland mit Hyperland Omachi und ich will wissen ob das in der VM funktioniert
Wayland in der VM hat richtige Probleme ich will einfach mal gucken ob das von uns
Doch WSL benutzt Hyper-V das neue WSL2 ist eigentlich auch nur eine Windows VM äh Quatsch keine Linux VM
geht nicht cash mit hyperland geht auch vor allem nicht setze ich weiß ich habe
es ja auch schon ein paar mal ausprobiert und es ging nie richtig
also ich denke mal ich werde etwas zu battlefield 6 machen wenn es dann rauskommt und wenn das bei
mir mit mit secure boot geht aber sollte ja eigentlich wir haben es ja ausprobiert
Immer noch kein Package-Update.
Schon eine Stunde nicht geupdatet.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Lass mal gucken.
I hate JavaScript.
Okay.
Okay, Chat, ihr könnt es euch aussuchen.
Wollen wir...
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Was haben wir denn hier noch zu bieten?
Chrome kriegt KI, oh ne, please.
Ich gucke den ab und zu ganz gerne.
Ich gucke mir auch nicht alles an,
Aber manche Sachen finde ich nice.
Und das mit I hate JavaScript wollte ich die ganze Zeit schon mal gucken.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das mal in einem anderen Stream an, weil wir ein bisschen am Basteln sind.
Okay, gucken wir uns das hier an.
Chrome kriegt KI. Das wird grausam.
KI-Videos ist immer so ein Ding, da bin ich immer am Meckern.
Guck mal hier, das bin ich, wie ich entspannt im Netz unterwegs bin und einfach mit meinem...
Also Chrome hat ja jetzt oben so einen KI-Button rechts in der Ecke.
So einen Gemini-Button.
Denn der sieht ja genau das, was ich auch sehe.
Ich kann also zum Beispiel fragen, was ist denn das da oben auf dem Foto?
Auf dem Screenshot siehst du eine Echtzeitkarte.
Aber niemand verwendet diesen AI-Button.
Edge hat jetzt ja auch so ein Ding, glaube ich, ne?
Dieser Kack-Browser, man.
Haben die nicht auch jetzt irgendwie so einen AI-Button hier oben bei Edge?
Da ist er doch hier, Copilot-Button.
Ich hoffe, Firefox fängt jetzt nicht auch noch mit dem Mist an.
Oder kann ich dieser Nachrichten-Website hier vertrauen?
Oder fasst mir mal kurz dieses Video hier zusammen.
Und ja, wie ihr vielleicht schon gesehen habt, das ist der ganz normale Chrome-Browser von Google.
Ich benutze den halt nur gerade mit einem US-Account und einem VPN in die USA, denn die sogenannten Gemini und Chrome...
Brave, ich weiß nicht. Auf dem Papier ist Brave irgendwie ganz nice, aber ich bin damit nie warm geworden. Ich weiß, ich mag Brave nicht.
Wie du sichere Hardware-Token-Devices einschmelzen.
Das ist ja ein Problem, was ich auch habe mit Hardware-Entsorgung.
Was ja eines der Gründe ist, warum ich mir einen Access Point angeschafft habe, der WLAN Passwörter vergeben kann pro Endgerät. Weil ich hatte mehr oder weniger genau das Problem, was du ansprichst. Was ist denn, wenn ich meinen Microcontroller in den Müll schmeiße? Da sind ja meine WLAN Zugangsdaten drauf. Oder was ist, wenn eine smarte Glühbirne kaputt ist? Da ist ja potenziell auch mein WLAN Passwort drauf.
und deswegen habe ich mir ein Access Point
vor ein paar Jahren gekauft, der
WLAN-Passwörter pro Gerät kann,
um genau sowas zu umgehen.
Wie du diese Geräte
am besten entsorgst, das ist echt
ein kompliziertes Thema, finde ich.
Geht eigentlich nur zerstören.
Wenn du die Mikrowelle
kaputt machen willst,
ähm,
Schreddern wäre gut.
Aber wer hat schon einen Schredder daheim?
Wo ist denn der Schaden, dein WLAN-Passwort irgendwo zu liegen?
Damit weiß der Finder ja nicht wo.
Der Finder, der sieht die Mülltonne vorm Haus stehen, greift rein und hat das Gerät mit dem WLAN-Passwort drauf.
Wo wird er wohl das WLAN dazugehörig finden?
eventuell hinter dem Haus, wo die Mülltonne davor steht.
... Funktionen sind in Europa noch nicht freigeschaltet.
Ja, ich will auch gar keine KI-Funktionen in meinem Browser.
USA.
Achso, übrigens, Leute, da ist ja nicht nur das Passwort drin gespeichert,
sondern auch der SSID-Name.
und den SSID Namen kannst du ja suchen. Es gibt ja Datenbanken von WLANs und da
kannst du nach der SSID suchen irgendwo im Umkreis.
Änder halt das Passwort, wenn du ein Gerät entsorgst. Weißt du was das für ein Akt ist?
Wenn du das komplette WLAN Passwort ändern musst auf allen Geräten nur weil
du ein Gerät entsorgst. Das ist das ist das da hast du tagelangen Aufwand.
Radioserver?
Ne, sowas mache ich nicht.
Radioserver.
Wozu soll ich einen Radioserver einrichten?
Du meinst für das WLAN?
Ne, das ist ja nicht WPA Enterprise.
Der Access Point kann
richtige WLAN Passwörter pro Gerät.
Nicht WPA Enterprise.
Die meisten Smart Home Geräte, IoT Geräte können ja gar kein WPA Enterprise.
So, mal kurz Video fertig gucken.
Rainbow Unicorn, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wird das Passwort denn in Plaintext gespeichert?
Ja, musst du ja.
Du brauchst das Passwort ja.
Im Flash von deinem Microcontroller liegt das Passwort im Plaintext.
Du brauchst es ja beim nächsten Login.
Also das IoT-Gerät, der Controller braucht das.
By the way, bin ich eigentlich der Einzige, der übelst genervt ist von diesem Trend der Hersteller, dass sie überall einen KI-Button hinmachen müssen oder überall KI-Features einbauen müssen, wo man sich immer fragt, warum?
Warum und vor allem, was ich mich immer frage, muss das wirklich in die Software direkt eingebaut sein? Tut es da nicht auch einen Add-on? Auch dieses ganze Copilot-Zeug, was mittlerweile unter Windows 11 vorinstalliert ist, geht mir mega auf den Sack.
Als ich gestern bisschen C++ gebastelt habe für ESP32, habe ich auch KI benutzt.
Ich frag dann Beispiel, gerade bei C++ ist ganz nice, mal so die KI zu fragen, sag mal
hast du eine Idee, wie man das schöner machen könnte?
Weil C++ einfach so eine abartige Abfucksprache ist.
Ich will jetzt aber kein C++ Rant starten.
Sonst geht es wieder los.
Trotzdem ist C++ in den Top 5 meiner Lieblingsprogrammiersprachen.
Das ist widersprüchlich, ich weiß.
Aber ich kann es nur damit begründen, dass manchmal auch, kann man auch auf andere Sachen übertragen,
manchmal machen auch abartige Sachen Spaß.
und C++ ist wirklich super abartig.
Aber das Gebasteln damit und gerade im Zuge für Microcontroller
macht halt richtig Spaß.
Weniger das C++, mehr mit C++ was für Microcontroller basteln.
Also meine Top 5 Lieblingsprogrammiersprachen.
Platz 1 teilt sich, würde ich sagen, Ruby und C Sharp.
eindeutig, die zwei
sind meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprachen.
Leider kann man so gut wie nichts mehr
in Ruby machen, weil Ruby on Rails
voll abgesägt
wurde, so quasi gibt es, keiner
verwendet mehr Ruby on Rails und es gibt auch
kaum neue Packages und Updates und alles
und ja, Ruby selbst ist eine super Sprache.
Mich würde freuen, wenn Ruby mal irgendwann
vielleicht noch so einen Revival
erlebt, aber Python
hat dem Ding ja komplett
den rang abgelaufen spätestens dank und machine learning aber trotzdem ruby ist eine super
programmiert sprache ist mega nice trotzdem die muss ich einfach auf platz eins packen weil es
gibt kaum eine sprache die die ich so in sich schön konsistent und und und optisch ansprechend
irgendwie finde wie ruby ja ja also ruby ist die schar danach würde ich tatsächlich sagen auch wenn
die sprache ganz viele wirren wäre sachen hat ich mag javascript
offen auf dem dritten platz javascript auf dem vierten platz
also sachen wie bash pack ich da gar nicht rein ja auf vier platz ist bei mir
go go ist auch so ein bisschen also ich habe mit go wahrscheinlich mehr sachen
fertig gekriegt als mit jeder anderen sprache aber go hat auch einige sachen
die mich nerven.
Aber wenn man einfach nur irgendwas auf die Reihe
kriegen muss, ist Go echt nice.
Und Go ist halt absolut top
für Command-Line-Tools und sowas.
Für Self-Contained-Binaries.
Es gibt nichts besseres als Go für diese
Geschichte.
Und Go hat halt auch ein riesengroßes Ökosystem.
Und wenn du was containerisieren willst, gibt es kaum
was besseres als eine Go-Anwendung zu haben.
So, und das fünfte ist
tatsächlich C++. Es ist abartig
als Fuck. Das ist eines der hässlichsten
und ekligsten
Programmiersprachen, die es gibt.
Aber ich mag halt das, was man damit macht.
Zum Beispiel
Microcontroller programmieren. Deswegen ist es bei mir auf Platz 5.
Und ich sage
absichtlich nicht C, C++,
weil C ist eine richtig
hübsche, in sich konsistente,
wenn auch sehr minimalistische Sprache mit
so quasi kaum vorhandener
Standardlibrary.
Und C++ ist es nicht.
C++ ist einfach ein riesen
Ausgeburt der Hölle.
Und abartig wie sonst was.
Inkonsistente Standard-Library, dafür relativ
viele Sachen drin. Und
Dinger, wo man sich fragt, was haben
sich die Standardisierer dabei nur gedacht?
Aber trotzdem, ist auf Platz 5.
Weil halt auch manchmal abartige Sachen Spaß machen können.
Haben wir was mit Haskell oder
Prolog gemacht?
Ne, weder noch.
Weil man von der Arduino-Sprache
zu C++ wechseln soll. Und Arduino ist
C++.
Da gibt es nichts zu wechseln.
Du verwendest schon C++.
Ich meine, Arduino hat so ein paar kleine Extensions
noch dabei, dass du
beispielsweise eine Funktion
unterhalb dem
definieren kannst, wo du sie drüber schon
benutzt und sowas. Aber
das ist, Arduino ist C++.
Also du verwendest schon C++.
Ich verwende allerdings mit dem
ESP32 mittlerweile kein
Arduino mehr. Ich verwende ISP-EDF.
Das ist das Framework
vom Hersteller. Das ist eigentlich ein reines
C-Framework, aber
das ist halt,
kannst du halt ohne Probleme C++ verwenden.
Das gefällt mir mittlerweile
besser. Bei Arduino
hat halt den riesen Vorteil, wenn du irgendwas brauchst,
was es nur als
Arduino Library gibt, dann
ja. Aber du kannst Arduino auch
in ESP-EDF als Modul verwenden,
wenn man das unbedingt braucht.
Aber du musst da eigentlich gar nichts wechseln.
Wie gesagt, Arduino ist C++.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns aber erstmal das Video
fertig an.
Funktion sind eine riesen Nummer,
diese Agenten. Und es gibt mit
BrowserOS sogar eine Open Source
Variante, die auf Wunsch mit
lokalen sprachmodellen funktioniert wo man also keine persönlichen daten in die usa stecken muss
das alles gucke ich mir hier mal genauer an und ich sage euch was ich für euch lohnen könnte und
welche versprochenen davon gibt es leider auch eine ganze menge und vor allem warum
bauen eigentlich auf einmal alle kai browser bleibt weil kai aktuell der heiße fit ist und
Und alle hoffen sich damit schnell Money machen, Money maken zu können.
Ich finde es übrigens mega nice, dass er für die Kontrolle von seinen Aufnahmen und Sachen einen Super Nintendo Controller verwendet.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet-Server, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
ja ich habe gerade schon erwähnt manchmal ist ein vpn super sinnvoll zum beispiel wenn man
die ki funktionen von chrome nutzen will man aber in europa wohnt und da kommt dort was sonst von
sein dieses video hat über 8000 mit denen wollte ich auch mal was machen aber da ist es nie dazu
gekommen war in 126 weil die haben festgestellt dass ich mal ein video gemacht habe gegen vpns
oder wo sich kritisch mit VPNs beschäftigt hat.
Da haben die gesagt, ich soll dieses Video löschen.
Da habe ich gesagt, ich will das Video nicht löschen.
Und dann haben wir nichts gemacht.
Wenn dann und ich Pech gehabt, würde ich sagen.
Werbung Ende.
Ja, was ist denn hier auf einmal los?
Alle Browser haben auf einmal KI-Funktionen.
Gibt es da irgendwo so einen KI-Hype oder so?
Gar nichts von mitbekommen.
Ja, okay, schlechter Scherz. Sorry.
Also ist klar.
Ja, irgendwas zu Battlefield 6 werde ich machen.
Niemand will irgendwas verpassen, ja vor allem nicht die großen Tech-Unternehmen und deshalb machen alle mit, aber zumindest sehr unterschiedlich.
So nutzt zum Beispiel Firefox, Open Source und nach wie vor mein persönlicher Lieblingsbrowser lediglich lokale KI-Modelle.
Firefox ist top.
Zum Beispiel die Tab-Gruppen automatisch zu gruppieren. Ist jetzt nichts weltbewegendes, aber zumindest nicht sinnlos.
Safari kann Zusammenfassungen von Websites mit Apple Intelligence machen.
Ich verwende gar keine Tab-Gruppen.
Verwendet ihr Tab-Gruppen?
Ich sollte vielleicht Tab-Gruppen verwenden, wenn ich mir sowas hier angucke, oder?
Wobei, es wäre Tab-Gruppe YouTube halt.
Okay, gut. Mag auch sinnvoll sein.
Also bei Firefox und Safari alles noch ganz soft.
Aber Google Chrome, immerhin meistgenutzter Browser der Welt, geht jetzt all in.
Seit ein paar Tagen gibt es in den USA die sogenannte Gemini in Chrome-Funktion.
Da hat man dann hier oben im Browserfenster dieses Icon und immer wenn man da draufklickt, schickt Chrome die aktuelle Ansicht an Gemini.
Googles großes Sprachmodell.
Und dann kann man halt Fragen stellen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ihr gerade ein Rezept seht, was euch gefällt, fragen, gibt es das auch irgendwie?
Gibt es wirklich Leute, die diese Funktion wollen und benutzen?
Ich sehe mich da überhaupt nicht.
Tragisch.
Und wenn ihr jetzt sagt, ist halt so ein kleines Chatbot-Fensterchen.
Kann ich doch sonst auch mit ChatGPT oder dem normalen Gemini oder Claude oder sonst einer KI machen?
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber der Punkt ist, dass Gemini in Chrome halt wirklich sieht, was ihr gerade seht.
Ihr müsst also nicht manuell die URL zum KI-Chatbot copy-pasten oder einen Screenshot machen,
sondern diesen Schritt spart ihr euch einfach.
Man kann das auch auf die Spitze treiben mit der sogenannten Live-Funktion.
Und da kann ich halt auf irgendwelchen Websites rumklicken und die ganze Zeit Fragen stellen.
Warum glänzt dieses Tier so?
Weil es nass ist.
Boah, krass.
Da wäre ich ohne KI nie drauf gekommen.
Was ist das?
Igel. Gibt es etwas Bestimmtes, das du über Igel wissen möchtest?
Ja, warum lacht der so?
Das ist ein lustiger Moment, oder? Es sieht fast so aus, als würde der Igel kichern.
Und ja, falls ihr euch gerade denkt, kostet das nicht super viel Energie?
Ja, das stimmt, weil das LLM die ganze Zeit aktiv ist und halt auch permanent Texte und Bilder gefüttert bekommt.
Eben das, was ihr da gerade im Browser...
Toll! Ich will natürlich unbedingt, dass alle meine Sachen zu Gemini geschickt werden.
Kann mir kaum was Besseres vorstellen.
... rausseht. Zu dem Energiethema kommt später nochmal was.
Aber ich muss wirklich sagen, dass sich das für mich schon ziemlich Science-Fiction-mäßig angefühlt hat,
dass man halt einfach mit so einem allwissenden Computer spricht, der vor allem die ganze Zeit den Kontext versteht.
Also ich bin ja gerade auf Webseiten und ich kann einfach über diese Webseiten reden und er versteht das.
Was ist das denn hier für ein lustiges Tier?
Das ist ein Goldstumpfnase. Sie leben in China und sind bekannt für ihre lustigen Gesichtsausdrücke.
China-Chinesen-Affe.
Computer reden, das geht natürlich auch mit anderen Voice-Chats.
Zum Beispiel ChatGPTs Advanced Voice, der so ganz unangenehmen Menschsein simuliert und immer so ein bisschen auf Kumpel macht.
Der kann ja auch sehen, aber nur das Kamerabild.
Oder kann der auch Screensharing? Fragen wir ihn mal selbst.
Du sag mal, ChatGPT, kann ich eigentlich meinen Bildschirm permanent mit dir teilen?
Also, dass du die ganze Zeit das siehst, was ich auch sehe?
Also, im Moment geht das leider nicht.
Ich kann nur ab und zu mal ein Screenshot oder ein Bild bekommen, wenn du mir das schickst.
aber ich kann nicht dauerhaft dein Bildschirm sehen.
Da sei aber aus technischen und auch Datenschutz...
Lame, ne?
Ja, ein bisschen ist es schon lame, das stimmt.
Aber wer weiß, vielleicht gibt es in Zukunft ja mal solche Features.
Im Moment müssen wir halt noch mit ein paar Screenshots auskommen,
aber wir machen einfach das Beste draus.
Machst du eigentlich jetzt hier so einen auf locker eigentlich?
Oder warum redest du so komisch?
Ach, weißt du, ich versuche einfach ein bisschen locker drauf zu sein,
damit das Ganze entspannt bleibt.
Dass ich mir so vorstellen kann, als würde ich mit dir in so einer Kneipe sitzen
und eine Cola trinken. Ganz genau.
So in etwa ist die Idee.
Also stell dir einfach vor, wir sitzen gemütlich irgendwo,
du mit deiner Cola, ich mit, naja,
was auch immer, virtuelle Assistenz zu trinken
und wir quatschen einfach entspannt.
Ganz entspannt.
Die Stimme von Gemini
in Chrome, die klingt deutlich weniger
menschlich. C3003 ist ein Kanal
vom Heise Verlag, einem bekannten deutschen
Verlag für Computerzeitschriften.
Aber wie gesagt, Gemini kann da halt immer
direkt... Hat Heise nicht jetzt sogar
Mindfactory gekauft? War da nicht was?
... sehen, was ich im Browser mache, also zumindest in diesem Live-Modus, den ich manuell einschalten muss.
Aber sonst läuft mein Browser-Fenster-Inhalt immer nur dann durchs LLM, wenn ich halt das Icon da oben anklicke.
Also es wird laut Google nicht grundsätzlich alles an die KI...
Okay, das ist ja schon mal was.
Aber Google hat ja auch schon...
Aber sagen wir mal so, sagt Google.
... angekündigt, dass Gemini in Chrome demnächst auch agentische Fähigkeiten bekommt.
Ja, und Agents sind ja nun wirklich gerade das dollste Ding seit Erfindung des tiefen Tellers und die stecken jetzt überall drin.
Agents versuchen nicht nur auf meinen Prompt irgendwie zu antworten, sondern versuchen sich auch irgendwie herzuleiten, wie sie zu dem hinkommen, was ich will.
Dafür können sie Tools benutzen und das ist in den meisten Fällen ein Browserfenster.
Die können da dann selbstständig drin rumklicken und Dinge eintippen.
Wir hatten dazu ja schon mal ein ausführliches Video über ChatGPT Agent, eines der aktuell meines Erachtens immer noch kompetentesten Agenten.
Aber auch der ist bei weitem noch nicht so intelligent wie ein Mensch.
Und zu der Werkzeugbenutzung übrigens gab es ja auch nochmal ein immer noch aktuelles Video hier zu der sogenannten MCP-Technik.
Ja, das haben wir uns angeguckt. Das fand ich cool.
Da hat es eine AI, die Blender bedienen kann.
Vielleicht auch interessant.
Also nicht, dass ich es verwenden würde, aber...
...on Chrome kommen diese Agent-Features bald, aber Perplexity hat ja schon vorgelegt, deren Agent...
Das waren die, die Chrome kaufen wollten, ne?
Ja, den gibt's schon.
Basierend übrigens auf Chromium, also dem Open Source Teil von Chrome, den alle benutzen dürfen.
Ja, und Comet macht seit ein paar Wochen richtig Welle.
Also man findet viel Hype-Getröte dazu und ständig behaupten Leute, dass sich durch Comet alles...
Verändert alles.
Wenn ich das irgendwo lese, dann weiß ich schon gleich, es verändert sich wahrscheinlich gar nichts.
Dieser KI-Browser verändert alles.
Ist geändert, hätte man...
Ja, ich habe Comet installiert und ziemlich viel damit ausprobiert und das ist halt eine Agent-Funktion, die den Browser bedienen kann.
Also erstmal prinzipiell genau das gleiche wie ChatGPT-Agent oder das Open Source Tool Browser Use oder Manus AI.
Ja, und wer kann Perplexity Comet benutzen?
Naja, es soll bald eine kostenlose Version kommen, aber zur Zeit geht es nur mit Perplexity Abo, was preislich ab 20 Dollar im Monat losgeht.
Und macht Comet jetzt wirklich alles besser als mein bisheriger Favorit ChatGPT Agent?
Manchmal ja, manchmal nein.
Und das ist halt zur Zeit noch das allergrößte Problem bei Agenten.
Da ist ein großer Zufallsfaktor drin.
Also wenn man denen beim Arbeiten zuschaut,
das sieht tatsächlich so ähnlich aus, als würde da jemand einfach so grob irgendwelche Sachen anklicken,
die aber nicht so richtig verstehen und manchmal hat man dann Glück.
Du trägst, oh nein, MP3, what?
Manchmal oder oft auch nicht.
Was ich zum Beispiel immer gerne mal ausprobiere mit Agents,
weil das halt wirklich eine Aufgabe ist, um die ich mich zurzeit kümmere.
Ich sage dem Agent, dass ich Merch produzieren will
und der mir mal raussuchen soll, 500 schwarze T-Shirts mit farbigen Druckkosten.
Gerne Bio, gerne Fairtrade.
Ja, und dann kommt Comet und sagt 505 Euro inklusive Mehrwertsteuer und Versand.
Und ich da natürlich, ja, das kann doch nicht sein, das ist ja nur 1 Euro pro T-Shirt.
Und obwohl Comet ganz klar ausgegeben hat, T-Shirts plus Druck tut Comet so, auf den Fehler angesprochen, ja, das klingt jetzt günstig für dich, aber meine Angabe bezieht sich ja natürlich nur auf den Druck. Das T-Shirt muss natürlich extra bezahlt werden. Als ob ich das nicht richtig verstanden hätte und er keinen Fehler gemacht hat. Also sehr wenig hilfreich und dazu dauerte das auch noch echt lange.
Weil Comet angeblich gut Statistiken verstehen kann, habe ich Comet mal Zugriff auf unsere CT3003 YouTube Analytics gegeben.
Und da habe ich gefragt, suchen wir mal raus, welche Videos die älteste Zuschauerschaft ansprechen und welche die jüngste.
Ja und am Ende kam einfach raus, dass das gleiche Video sowohl die älteste als auch die jüngste Zuschauerschaft hat.
Ja, was offenbar einfach daran lag, dass Comet nicht in der Lage war, sich durch mehrere Videos zu klicken, sondern einfach immer nur das aktuelle angeguckt hat.
Typisches Problem bei Agenten, dass sie sich halt irgendwie komisch festfahren.
Was Comet auf jeden Fall besser kann als die Konkurrenz, einfach weil es ein Browser ist,
man kann den Comet-Agenten mit einem Prompt auf mehrere Tabs loslassen.
Und das ist so ein bisschen Fluch und Segen zugleich.
Wenn man nämlich Comet als Hauptbrowser verwendet, ist man ja auf vielen Sites eingeloggt,
was ja dem Agenten sehr zugute kommt, weil ja eben vieles nur mit Login funktioniert.
Der ChatGPT-Agent dagegen wird häufig ausgesperrt, vor allem von Google-Services.
Klar ist Konkurrenz und das löst Comet dann halt auf die Weise, dass es eben in meinem persönlichen Browser läuft.
Und trotzdem aber in vielen Fällen nicht besser funktioniert als ChatGPT-Agent, der ja auch oft nur Quatsch fabriziert.
Also schon mal als Zwischenfazit.
Man braucht sehr spezifische Aufgaben, bei denen Agents heute schon sinnvoll hätten.
Hat mich jetzt nicht überzeugt, dass ich den Kram verwenden will und ihr?
Für meine Arbeit und auch für mein Privatleben habe ich solche Use Cases noch nicht gefunden, was nicht heißen soll, dass sie nicht gibt.
Also wenn ihr was ganz Konkretes habt, wo euch Comet oder ChatGPT Agent oder ein anderer Agent regelmäßig Zeit und Nerv sparen,
schreibt das gerne in die Kommentare oder an 3003.http.de.
Das interessiert uns wirklich, weil wir auch noch nicht so viele gute Beispiele gesehen haben für diese Agents.
Aber vielleicht sind wir auch nur unkreativ.
Naja, aber ganz wichtig, jetzt kommen wir mal zum Elefanten im Raum.
Warum pusht Perplexity eigentlich so stark den eigenen Browser?
Die wollten ja sogar zeitweise mal Chrome kaufen, weil Google Ärger mit den US-Behörden hatte.
Hm, so Kartellen und so.
Aber das ist durch, Chrome bleibt vorerst bei Google und Perplexity macht sein eigenes Ding.
Der Perplexity-Chef Aravind Srinivas hat im April gesagt, dass einer der Hauptgründe für die Browser-Fixierung seiner Firma sei,
Wir wollen auch die Daten sammeln, die bei den Usern außerhalb der Perplexity-App anfallen.
Also halt alle Daten, auch die, die gar nichts mit KI-Nutzung zu tun haben,
weil man ja den Comment-Browser als Hauptbrowser benutzen soll.
Das will Perplexity richtig doll.
Aber warum sollte ich das wollen?
Denn nicht irgendwelche Pop-Ups auf, die dazu auffordern.
Also habe ich die ganze Zeit weggeklickt.
Weil, sagt auf jeden Fall Srinivias, die Leute nutzen KI oft nur für Arbeitssachen,
Sachen, nicht so für Privates,
aber den Browser benutzen sie halt
für alles und man will ja auch an die
privaten Sachen ran. Also wenigstens ist er
ehrlich und er sagt halt auch, dass
Complexity hyperpersonalisierte
Werbung verkaufen will und dass die Leute
das dann auch mit dem Datensammeln okay fänden,
weil sie dann ja bessere Werbung
Ja, da bin ich auch dafür.
Ich möchte unbedingt noch bessere
Werbung haben und dafür alle meine Daten
hergehen. Ja, das ist logisch.
Was sonst?
Ja, ich lasse das mal so stehen. Wenn ihr in das Datenschutz versus Perplexity-Comet-Thema detaillierter rein wollt, empfehle ich euch dieses Video hier vom hochgeschätzten Morpheus.
Ja, wenn ihr gerne mal so einen argentischen Browser ausprobieren wollt und trotzdem sich nicht vorstellen wollt, dass eure Daten nicht euren Rechner verlassen.
Ja, da gibt es was. Das ist Open Source, nämlich Browser-OS. Basiert auch auf Chromium und verbindet sich auf Wunsch mit LLMs in der Cloud, also von OpenAI oder von Google oder Entropic.
Aber, und das finde ich natürlich sehr aufregend, kann man da auch lokale LLMs anbinden.
Und da passierte ja in den letzten Monaten ziemlich viel.
Zum Beispiel kamen da zwei frei nutzbare LLMs von OpenAI raus oder auch hier eins von Alibaba namens Qen3.
Meiner Grafikkarte mit 24 GB schnellen Speicher habe ich diese beiden hier ausprobiert.
Gehören auch so ziemlich zu den vielversprechendsten.
Ja, aber leider, was soll ich sagen, keiner der beiden war in BrowserOS in der Lage, einfachste Arbeiten zu machen.
Also zum Beispiel den aktuell meist gelesenen Artikel auf heise online anzuklicken, obwohl man
dann nur ein bisschen runterscrollen muss und da dann die meist gelesenen Artikel aufgelistet sind.
Die kommerziellen Agents schaffen das alle problemlos.
Naja und wenn man Flüge buchen will, dann kommt da sowas raus.
Aha, okay. Null Umstiege für 200 Euro. Weiß ich nicht. Ist glaube ich nicht richtig.
Ja, das war übrigens das 12 GB große GPT OSS 20B. Etwas besser hat bei meinem Test das 18 GB
große Qen 3 30B Modell in BrowserOS abgeschnitten.
Aber bei diesem Test hier, wo ich BrowserOS mit Qen...
Also kann man vergessen.
Aber das ist ja nicht schlimm, weil ich will sie nicht verwenden.
...Qen 3, ChatGPT Agent, Perplexity Comic und Manus gleichzeitig gepromptet habe.
Und zwar mit der Anfrage, mir einen Flug von Hannover nach Tokio zu suchen.
Möglichst günstig, unter 19 Stunden.
Ja, da ist BrowserOS auch in einer halben Stunde nicht darüber hinaus gekommen, Hannover
ins Feld hier einzugeben.
Ja, und Manus ist auch hängen geblieben.
Comet und ChatGPT Agent haben es hinbekommen, aber mit deutlichen Unterschieden.
Der ChatGPT Agent Flug war heftige 400 Euro günstiger als der von Comet.
Also da ist generell noch viel Potenzial nach oben.
Ganz klar ist aber auch, dass der Kampf um eure Daten gerade erst angefangen hat.
Ja, das muss euch leider klar sein, dass eure Daten, um euch möglichst passgenaue Werbung anzuzeigen, ein großer Motivator für den Ganzen.
Man muss sich halt immer überlegen,
wenn was kostenlos
angeboten wird,
dann müssen die ja irgendwie gucken, wie sie an Kohle
kommen.
Da seid ihr meistens so. Wie sagt man so schön?
Da seid ihr das Produkt.
Ihr bezahlt das
unterm Strich immer irgendwie.
Rare Stream. So, Rare ist
der jetzt für die letzten
Wochen gar nicht.
Dankeschön für 200 Bits.
... ein KI-Hype ist. Und natürlich nicht nur bei Perplexity, sondern auch bei anderen Unternehmen.
Wenn ihr KI verwenden wollt, würde ich euch natürlich am liebsten empfehlen, lokale Sprachmodelle zu nehmen.
Aber ja, die sind immer noch ziemlich weit von der Qualität von ChatGPT und Co. entfernt.
Deshalb würde ich zumindest empfehlen, Standalone-KI-Angebote zu nutzen, also einzelne Websites wie ChatGPT oder Apps,
statt komplett auf einen KI-Browser umzusteigen.
So könnt ihr zumindest selbst entscheiden, welche Daten ihr an den KI-Anbieter geben wollt und welche nicht.
Bei einem KI-Browser oder sogar einem KI-Betriebssystem, ja, da sieht der Anbieter womöglich alles, was ihr macht.
Also alles.
Und was man auch bedenken muss, die großen Tech-Firmen investieren gerade gigantische, also wirklich so noch nie dagewesene Summen in KI-Rechenzentren.
Also Amazon 118 Milliarden Dollar nur für 2025, Microsoft 80 Milliarden, Google 85 Milliarden, Meta ungefähr 70 Milliarden.
Ja, stonks.
Und die ganze KI-Rechenpower, die da entsteht, mit der muss man ja irgendwas machen, ne?
Und die Investitionen, die sollen ja auch wieder eingespielt werden.
Deshalb ist schon jetzt klar wie Kloßbrühe, wir werden überschwemmt werden mit KI-Funktionen.
Egal, ob sinnvoll oder nicht, erstmal ausprobieren, mal gucken, was hängen bleibt.
Und ja, okay, der Strom für diese gigantischen Rechenzentren, der kann realistischerweise aktuell nicht mit Erneuerbaren erzeugt werden.
Das heißt für die Betreiber Dinge verbrennen und irgendwie CO2-Ausgleichszertifikate brauchen.
Gut, das ist ja Kritik, was generell bei AI und auch bei Kryptowährungen und so immer mitschwingt.
... noch als Freund der Erde darstellen kann.
Was am Ende rauskommt, weiß ich nicht.
Es wäre unseriös, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, dass ich das wüsste.
Also es kann sein, dass in den dicken Rechenzentren am Ende, keine Ahnung, Krebs ausgerottet wird, weil die KI ein Heilmittel findet.
Das ist tatsächlich eine Hypothese, die ich jetzt nicht aus der Luft gegriffen habe.
Das ist eine These, die ich schon häufiger gehört habe.
Gleichzeitig sagt aber sogar Meta-Boss Mark Zuckerberg, dass KI eine Blase sein könnte, die platzen kann.
Also die Wahrheit liegt wahrscheinlich irgendwo dazwischen. Tschüss.
Also hat mich jetzt nichts irgendwie darauf heiß gemacht, dass ich das unbedingt verwenden will, ne?
Absage ohne Ende, junge Leute, ja, trotz Fachkräftemangel.
Ja, ich lese immer die ganzen Boomer, die sich da drüber aufregen, dass die aktuelle Generation, die will ja einfach nicht arbeiten und sowas.
ich glaube das stimmt nicht
ich glaube es ist eher so
dass die einfach keinen Bock mehr haben
zu den Konditionen und Bedingungen
zu arbeiten
wie
es früher der Fall war
also ich habe den Eindruck
dass zumindest
bilde ich mir das ein
dass die Leute heute deutlich
mehr darauf gucken dass die Arbeit
nicht ihr Leben ist
Ich habe zwei Bachelor-Aufgaben und einen Master.
Bachelor-Abschlüsse, einen Master.
Äh, kein Bock.
You're all sitting in one boat.
Razzia im Bahnhofsviertel.
Oh, vier...
Okay.
Das ist mir eigentlich...
Was macht er denn da?
Das ist mir eigentlich zu lang, aber...
Aber Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel könnte man sich tatsächlich geben.
Aber vielleicht nicht jetzt.
Ihr wisst, wenn ich ein 34-Minuten-Video gucke,
dann bin ich ja fast eine Stunde damit beschäftigt.
Ich kenn mich.
Aber noch irgendwas Kurzes vielleicht?
Das haben wir doch schon geguckt.
Das haben...
Ich hab Hunger.
Was ist das?
Rutsche.
Die bauen da immer Zeug.
CCC Vorträge...
Das dauert auch so lang.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Nein, es gibt keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Heute.
Es gibt Nudeln mit Carbonara.
Carbonara.
Auch keine Bolognese, ne.
Ich guck keinen Fußball.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, ja, ich weiß auch nicht.
Das ist schon ganz schön
abweichend vom Standard.
Chat, vielleicht
machen wir nachher noch ein bisschen
C++
gebastelt auf dem ESP32.
Warum sollte ich Offstream basteln, wenn ich mich
auch Onstream über C++ aufregen kann?
Was ist das?
Moment, ich guck mal.
Verschlucken wir acht Spinnen im Schlaf.
Warte.
Machen wir das?
Das ist doch Blödsinn, oder?
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich schon Spinnen verschluckt hab.
Bestimmt habt ihr schon mal gehört, dass jeder Mensch in seinem Leben durchschnittlich
acht Spinnen im Schlaf verschluckt.
Und vielleicht habt ihr schon mal gehört, dass das tatsächlich gar nicht stimmt.
Was ihr aber sicher noch nie gehört habt, ist die wilde Geschichte hinter dieser Urban
Legend.
In diesem Video erzähle ich sie euch.
Denn bei meinen Recherchen habe ich entdeckt, dass dahinter nicht nur einer, sondern sogar
ein doppelter Fake steckt, der selbst erfahrene Internetnutzer seit Jahrzehnten immer wieder
hinter das Licht führt. Was eine mysteriöse
Journalistin mit all dem zu tun hat,
was Mediziner und Spinnenexperten
zu dem Gerücht sagen und wie KI
die Gesellschaft heutzutage auf die Füße macht,
erfahrt ihr jetzt.
Wenn ihr neu hier seid, willkommen, ich heiß Mats,
ich bin Journalist und ich recherchiere
für euch, was wirklich hinter den Schlagzeilen
von Medien, YouTubern und
Social Media steckt. Ich hab übrigens auch
einen zweiten Kanal, der heißt Mats Appreciated
und da spreche ich auch über
andere Themen und erzähle vor allem
positive Geschichten. Im neuesten Video geht es zum Beispiel um das unbekannte Vermächtnis von
Alphabrei. Als ich Dr. Jason Dunlop auf die Sache mit dem Spinnenverschlucken anspreche,
weiß er sofort, wovon ich rede. Der Zoologe ist am Berliner Naturkundemuseum für die
Spinnentiere zuständig und hört diese Behauptung schon seit 20 Jahren. Doch er kann sofort Entwarnung
geben. In der Fachliteratur gibt es keinerlei Hinweise darauf, dass Menschen im Schlaf Spinnen
verschlucken. Was tatsächlich passieren könne, wenn auch sehr selten, ist, dass kleine
Spinnen versehentlich ins Ohr krabbeln. Das beruhigt mich jetzt aber weniger.
Wahrscheinlich, weil sie es als dunklen sicheren Unterschlupf betrachten. Solche Fälle findet man
auch in der Fachliteratur. Das ist ja noch ekliger. Das nächtliche Verschlucken ist hingegen nicht
dokumentiert. Der Spinnenexperte hält es schon deswegen für unrealistisch, weil unser Körper
beim Schlafen ja Vibrationen und Luftbewegungen verursacht, was Spinnen eher verscheuche. Die
Die meisten Spinnen können nicht so besonders gut sehen, sagt er mir.
Dafür haben sie sogenannte Hörhaare.
Das sind feine Borsten auf den Beinen, die Luftbewegungen wahrnehmen.
Ein großer, vibrierender menschlicher Mund oder Körper könnte darum abschreckend wirken.
Aber sagen wir mal, eine Spinne entschließt sich aus irgendeinem Grund doch dazu,
in die Nähe unseres Mundes zu krabbeln.
Selbst dann ist sehr zweifelhaft, dass wir sie verschlucken würden.
Wenn man die Anatomie unseres Mundes und Rachens sowie die Physiologie unseres Schlafes kennt,
ist das fast unmöglich, erklärt der Schlafmediziner Dr. Erich Vogt 2009.
gegenüber dem Magazin Self. Selbst wenn alle Umstände perfekt zusammentreffen,
zum Beispiel in einer sehr spinnenreichen Umgebung, wäre die Wahrscheinlichkeit äußerst gering. Das
liegt an den Schutzmechanismen unseres Körpers. Zum Beispiel würden wir eine Spinne in der Regel
auf der Haut spüren und dann entweder aufwachen oder sie wegwischen. Und im unrealistischen Fall,
dass doch eine Spinne in den Mund gelangen sollte, würden weitere Abwehrsysteme greifen,
wie Würgereflex, Husten und...
...Kotzt erstmal aufs Bett und weiß nicht warum...
...die geschlossenen Schließmuskeln der Speiseröhre.
Nur wenn alle diese Schutzbarrieren nacheinander überwunden werden, könnte man theoretisch eine Spinne verschlucken.
Das ist aber extrem unwahrscheinlich.
Und dass es gleich viele Male im Leben passiert, ist praktisch unmöglich.
Dennoch verbreitet sich die Behauptung seit Jahrzehnten hartnäckig auf der ganzen Welt.
In den meisten...
Das habe ich aber auch schon mal gehört. Das habe ich sogar schon noch Zeiten gehört vor, also prä-Internet.
In den meisten Versionen sind es acht Spinnen, die wir im Laufe unseres Lebens angeblich verschlucken.
In anderen ist von 10 die Rede oder von 50 oder sogar von 20.000.
Noch verrückter wird das alles aber, wenn man sich auf die Suche nach dem Ursprung...
Du schläfst nur noch mit Ohrstöpseln?
Ich schlafe manchmal mit so einem Band um den Kopf.
Da sind so ganz kleine Lautsprecher drin.
Da kann man auf der Seite liegen und die stören nicht großartig.
Kapitel 2. Es war einmal eine Journalistin.
Ich selbst habe die Behauptung vom Spinnenverschlucken zum ersten Mal auf dem Schulhof gehört.
Ja, ich glaube auch. Und das ist schon ewig her. Das war noch pre-Internet.
Erst Jahre später erfuhr ich dann, dass sie überhaupt nicht stimmt.
Das passt auch zu den Medienberichten, die ich bei meiner Recherche finde.
Vor allem in den 90ern und Anfang der 2000er wurde die Geschichte immer wieder munter verbreitet.
Sei es in Büchern, Zeitungsartikeln oder Internetforen.
Erst gegen Mitte und Ende der...
ASMR? Nö.
Meistens, ich gucke ganz gerne auf dem Handy
abends noch irgendwie
Gaming-Videos auf YouTube
oder manchmal Twitch oder so.
Und was ich auch manchmal mache, ist,
ich mache manchmal so einfach
Rauschen an.
Gerade wenn irgendwie draußen ein bisschen Krach ist
oder so, mache ich einfach Rauschen an. Das kann man
auch gut pennen bei.
Nuller Jahre sickerte allmählich durch, dass sie
eigentlich völliger Quatsch ist. Und woher
kommt das Märchen? Wer hat es in die Welt gesetzt?
Darüber ist man sich inzwischen einig.
In die Welt gesetzt hat es die Journalistin Lisa Holst im Jahr 1993.
Das Spinnengerücht wurde demnach von der Kolumnistin Lisa Holst im Jahr 1993 in die Welt gesetzt.
In die Welt gesetzt hat dieses Märchen die Journalistin Liza Holst im Jahr 1993.
This myth became so widespread...
Alter, ich kann mir das halt angucken, so viele Spinnen.
Das ist ja eklig.
Das guckt mir nicht an, so viele Spinnen.
Ich bin echt kein großer Spinnen-Fan.
Spodas.
Der Drachenlord ist zu ihr.
Das hat mir jetzt noch...
Das war mir jetzt noch wissen müssen.
In den Empfehlungen
irgendwie nichts drin.
Männer, wenn sie 30 werden,
was soll ich denn sagen? Ich bin erst 40 geworden.
Naja, chat.
ich gehe jetzt was futtern und wenn es mir danach ist ich kann nichts
versprechen wenn es mir da ist basteln wir nachher noch ein bisschen bis später
leute wir hören uns macht's gut cu